[Laughter]
hey you guys what's going on
[Laughter]
okay we're gonna go out tonight so we
don't know how long the stream's gonna
last well it's only five o'clock i mean
we have a lot of time and honestly if if
we have to i can just like uh cake more
makeup on over this makeup and just
change clothes
yeah we're just going to go simple
anyway man
yeah i'm not you can't see don't get all
dolled up that much because
all right
so
let's see who we got in there
yeah we got lots of people david june
says btk better make an appearance this
episode we'll see i just moved him oh
i still haven't figured that out
that moving one way or the other it's
always opposite he's like right back
there
him and hh or both hh homes are back
there on the thing trying to get into
the camera yeah it's just
all right he's moving around moving
around yeah yeah well btk shows up when
when when when you know when if he's
deciding to actually project from his
cell
sometimes he'll [ __ ] come in like
that that's right already
really seriously the stream's [ __ ] up
come on okay should i go down here and
reset the router no
just it does it again we'll reset the
router it's the beginning of the damn
show yeah all right i mean um
yeah when you so you said like when
dennis chooses to astrally project from
his yeah then sometimes
yeah sometimes i will [ __ ] allow him
to take over slightly still alive right
yeah
i hadn't heard that he died yeah but you
know i haven't been keeping up with all
the
serials
asking where seagal was seagal is
actually [ __ ] leading one of the
wings of the [ __ ] uh the russian
[ __ ] mission into ukraine he's he led
the amphibious uh assault because he can
float because of all the foot because of
all the facts they got him up in the
front look at he's just flirting
he's like like
in the water he didn't even speak
russian he just go there this is what i
want you guys well he just wants
everyone to speak steve i want you to go
i want you guys to put on a good show
when you're out there and when you aim
aim true when you raise up the rifle
make sure to put the rifle on your
shoulder and pull the trigger pull the
trigger with your finger don't pull you
that's that's
[Laughter]
only thing i can tell you guys you guys
are well trained you know what you have
to do
my advice is you have to go up and down
stairs just ask for your stunts
yeah
yeah
he thinks every one of them [ __ ]
russian soldiers
i wish i had a stunt double yeah
yeah how cool would that be it's like
hey can you just go get my towels out of
the dryer thanks
i don't feel like walking down the
stairs
i've had a good i've had an enjoyable
time
watching all the [ __ ] generals and
the talking heads on [ __ ] all the uh
the news channels they they get these
loser ass generals like general keane he
he was on cnn and fox news i watched
that dude lie his way through like three
or four wars during the time
starting back in the in the early 90s
and he just sucking
i don't have a big respect for
the general staff officers in general if
they're on tv they're liars that's why
they're on tv
their shills for the
[ __ ]
contractors
that make make all this money off the
pentagon so
all they do is just go yeah they
shouldn't have done it we're gonna you
know
and uh you know we're we're gonna take
care of those real quick they bit off
more than they could do we got and
there's just kind of these stock
androids we need to spend more money
if they hadn't bought that new money if
they'd bought the new money then the new
money would make them new missiles and
then we would have no problem but they
don't listen to us you know just that's
just that same [ __ ] over and over again
um
it's i just find it hilarious
and uh most of their predictions don't
turn out and
just uh although kane's gotten good at
it at saying
something without saying anything
to make it sound like he told you
something when when in fact he avoided
[ __ ] telling you something that could
be used against him later just more
shillery
shilling and shilling
making money
oracle says i have some scary news to
share
this monday my husband had to rush me to
the er for symptoms that included me
bleeding so badly there was blood on the
floor holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
i mean hopefully you're okay i guess
you're okay enough because you're here
now luckily i went home after a couple
hours but i'm going in for some surgery
week after next oh that sucks damn i
mean i hope you're okay i ain't gonna
make any jokes i don't know where you're
bleeding from yeah that's that's not
good yeah don't joke about that yeah
it's not funny oh yeah that's just not
funny uh yes they put me on some huge
drugs to deal with the symptoms well you
know that that might be a plus right if
if they're the good drugs right so yeah
we're all thinking about childhood
hopefully it goes okay
but yeah uh we have somebody in the
comments called black steven seagal it
looks it i think it's i think it's uh
murder hornets it looks like the same
avatar yeah but um
yeah
it's good to know that the cigars come
in all colors
i just totally pictured
like a collector's set yeah i have a
whole bunch of stephen seagal action
figures like in every color of the
rainbow well he does come in all colors
he does every [ __ ]
voice he speaks in [ __ ]
chinese and japanese accents
[ __ ] ebonics maybe that's why he
thinks he doesn't have to learn any
languages he's like look if i just talk
in the spoke all these like english but
like in the accent then they'll
understand what i'm saying if you ask me
because no i i speak because i speak
seven languages yeah like he'll go to
italy and be like that's a spicy
meatball
like in english
it's a sign of a [ __ ] pathological
liar man
i'll tell you what i've been in italy
seven years now
this is a greater meatball
yeah i need to speak to don you need to
speak to don corleone
yeah yeah oh my god yeah
holy [ __ ] i will tell you one thing
though
i thought he was sleeping with the
fishes no before you but okay um yeah
you can't call them anymore no but uh
you know what though one thing that i
learned fairly recently that actually
kind of i don't know if it like blew my
mind but it blew my mind a little bit it
was like it was like that
um that chef boyardee which you know i
loved as a kid actually i'll still eat
it nowadays i'm not proud uh but that
was that was based on a real dude yeah
and and that was [ __ ] and that was his
real name that's not how you spell it no
yeah it's boy arty but uh it's spelled
like an italian way but they said well
we need to like americanize it up a
little bit because no one don't know how
to pronounce that yeah but i was just
kind of like oh i thought i thought that
was like some [ __ ] aunt jemima or a
little debbie or somebody or you know
betty crocker or like a person that
didn't exist they're like no that was a
real person and the guy that's on the
can that was him yeah i saw like a video
about it i was like gordon ramsay of the
early 1900s he was he was like he was
[ __ ] hot at the you know making the
[ __ ] stuff
he was uh
cooking for kings and cooking in huge
hotels for giant you know for big
[ __ ] basically like bilderberg groups
with all the damn billionaires showing
up
he had a good menu you know looking he
he was cooking nowadays you wouldn't be
impressed but back then you know it
would be considered like a well i mean
it was easier to impress people back
with food well they weren't used to
[ __ ] like well it's not full of
maggots so when they weren't used to
like varied diets and having things from
all over the world like what it has like
like salt and pepper on it wow
that's really something
italian food before that was even a
thing well yeah
and to be honest with you um i'm gonna
defend
i haven't had it in a few years
but just like a couple years back
somebody like 2015 or something i
actually have got some of those little
cups of like chef boyardee stuff like
for lunch if i didn't have anything else
like at work
yeah or you know from 7-eleven or
whatever and those are like actually
still pretty decent yeah i mean it's not
it's not gourmet food or anything like
that but i mean they're still like
it's not gross they're a lot better than
they were yeah and yeah actually a lot
of stuff because i'm going to say like
chef boyardee i loved that [ __ ] as a kid
because my uh my grandma always had it
in the in the uh you know the cupboard
for like for the kids to eat for lunch
because all of us stayed over there in
the summer
and the spaghetti and meatballs and the
like double stuff ravioli or like the
big ravioli were like my favorite ones i
wasn't a big fan of the bee ferroni but
that was okay too i would do in a pinch
but
i mean there was nothing wrong with them
then but
uh it's a lot better than franco
american that's for sure because that
was like some watery [ __ ] right
there
i never liked spaghettios yeah but
there's a lot of stuff about segal in
there
he's he's always such a he you know what
i wouldn't be surprised if he contacted
me at some point and wanted like
royalties because we talk about him all
the time and he's just kind of like you
guys are using my name like to make
money and i want a piece of that pie i'm
like yeah here's a dollar that's about
it that's probably about how much it's
like of all the of all the videos we
produced over the years like the
percentage of time that we've talked
about him and like the money that we've
made from that it's probably like about
a buck or so maybe not even that much
yeah
stixx asks
does black seagull also run like a [ __ ]
the answer is
well eyeballs around them i kind of feel
like they all do because if there was a
cigar that didn't run like a [ __ ]
um and didn't have a stunt double that
walked upstairs and stuff like that then
it wouldn't be a cigar it would be a
cool person
so but uh yeah somebody out there i mean
you couldn't call it steven seagal you'd
have to call it like
i don't know
even small or something like that but
it's like you could make like this whole
collector's thing that's obviously him
but you can't use his name but it has to
look
what's the rules on that because i know
that
you can't um
you know if you're a celebrity you can't
just like make an action figure of any
[ __ ] you want because you do
have to like pay licensing fees for
their image
but
i'm like well how different does an
action figure have to look
to
let to let you like slide on that i'd
wonder i wonder if anybody's like that's
entertainment lawyer or any or a
copyright lawyer or anything like that
because i'm always kind of curious about
copyright laws
you know what i mean
uh let's see
little ball of fur
says uh what where was i
let's see
um wait a minute oh my god i missed like
a whole [ __ ] conversation because we
were like so
we're so obsessed with that [ __ ]
uh
yeah seagal is racially ambiguous after
all
uh
he's not really ambiguous he's steven
seagal
instantly transforms into whatever race
he's speaking to at the moment
it's his superpower if you show up black
he becomes black if you show up chinese
becomes good at chinese
actually if you just start talking about
the chinese he becomes chinese he does
all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
and and i'm not making it up got it on
video to prove it they've made whole
they've made whole [ __ ] youtube
uh videos i love the running car every
one of his damn accents and the context
if i'm ever in a bad mood one day i
could just watch one of the running
compilations
that many people have done on youtube
and it's like that'll cheer me right up
yeah
if he's talking to a black person he
immediately goes into fakie bionics
and you're not supposed to notice or
it's supposed to make him cool i don't
know what it is
i've never understood that at all it's
like why would you want to talk like the
other person that's like that's creepy
that's like some [ __ ] scientologists
would do that's exactly what i was
thinking because that's something that
the scientologist they tell you to do
tell you to do that it's all about that
tone scale thing and you're supposed to
like approach people the same way that
they're approaching you like not so much
talk like they talk but you're supposed
to kind of like mirror them a little bit
because i guess and i don't know like
this is a long ago study so i don't know
if this has been backed up lately or not
but there was a thing that
people tend to like people better who
are more like them
so the thinking behind it is if you meet
somebody new and you want to like
recruit them
then you're supposed to come at them
like with the same kind of energy
that yeah so and that's supposed to make
them like you better it doesn't work
though no i don't think i've seen people
do that to me it comes off like a sales
tactic
well it comes off and like i said i had
people do that when i when i uh worked
with them in clear water and yeah it
just comes off as super creepy i'm like
are you are you guys like serial killers
or what the [ __ ] it comes off like
really really off-putting yeah i think
um because being themselves
yeah yeah and you can tell that they're
not being like it's like you showed up
to like
they're kind of like one of the kind of
like not kind of like one of the face
girls from [ __ ] disney
they come off like that do you guys ever
know about walt disney culture because
there's just so many disney employees
around here there's fur and face
and the people that dress up in the damn
fur costumes you never see their faces
the girls and and the guys that play
humans in in the cartoons they call them
face
or face actors or face performers
and they have to look like that person
there's a little thing that they go
through and everything
and when they're
out in the park
they are being that role and it's you
can interact with them but it's very
artificial very fake
yeah because they're coming across like
yeah i'm ariel i'm a real mermaid
they have to act like the character yeah
just like that little character and when
somebody matches you
that does that
it it comes across kind of like that
kind of like somebody at it
off the disney theme park and i mean at
least at disney you know that they're
doing that i mean they're doing it for
the sake of little kids mostly because
they don't want to like break the
illusion that this is like the actual
character
so i get that but you know you're paying
for that experience but i was i'm not
paying for like some weirdos to like
come up and
try to pretend to be me while they're
talking to me part of it could be that
uh it's gonna make me wanna hit you
people that are doing it are
scientologists and scientologists are
not particularly talented or really all
that intelligent they think they are but
they're not
well that's what's so funny i think
that's what um
kind of pissed me off the most about
them well and like i said i worked for
him i only worked there for eight months
and i couldn't take it anymore at first
i just kind of thought it was funny
because i'm just like okay what if you
do you whatever but after a while i just
kind of got sick of it but one of the
things that pissed me off about them the
most was that they thought they were
super super smart like smarter than
everybody else and like way more
superior and they clearly were not they
were kind of idiots yeah and i was just
kind of like that is like my least
favorite kind of person they're like
larpers
they're like they're larp i'm like if
and i'm not judging like if people are a
dummy or something like that i don't
care about that as long as you are aware
enough to know that you know that you're
a dummy or whatever
but these people that
think that they're way smarter than
everyone but they're really not yeah and
they're just like and actually are kind
of idiots um those people just like
really really get on my nerves like the
dunning-kruger [ __ ] the best
one is marty rathbun marty rathbone and
he got kicked out and he's he's still a
scientologist he still believes that
[ __ ]
but he's probably the best one
i mean at least he's somewhat normal
yeah
he seems like a mostly normal person tom
cruise is also probably one of the
better ones
you know he's kind of weird too i got a
thing yeah but you know but that's like
one of the better better was yeah
well like i said he didn't get the whole
experience we've talked about that
before he didn't get the same experience
that like your scientologist on the
ground would get
so he you know he doesn't have that
weird and like i said the the creepiest
ones are the ones that were raised in it
that are like second and third
generation
because i worked with a bunch of those
and they were like 16 17 years old and
their parents were scientologists they
didn't know any different they had just
grown up in this bubble
so their interactions with regular
people were very off-putting yeah i
found them very off-putting and it's
it's something when you're in your you
know 20s or 30s and you have some
15 year old kid
thinking they're like some superior
alien race or something like talking to
you and you're just like you're kind of
stupid aren't you
but you know it's they they don't want
to hear it they don't want to hear it dj
maniac says i see you guys just reviewed
demon knight yes we did i just watched
bordello of blood this past week yeah i
think shutter added both of them
as well as like tails from the hood and
stuff honestly i don't mind bordello of
blood i think i mentioned it on the
demon knight review but it's like dennis
miller is kind of annoying in it but i
mean he's kind of annoying in general
but uh and ep's even more annoying now
than he used to be back then but
i mean i don't mind bordeaux blood but i
think demon knight is a better
movie you know what i'm saying
uh let's see
double stuff ravioli that's where it's
at man
and honestly like i said i got it a few
years back
just because i was at work and i forgot
to bring my lunch that day
and i got i think it was ravioli it's
still pretty it was pretty damn good
it's the pasta is a little mushy but i
don't mind that
you know
what are you gonna do it's it's out of a
can so
uh
only tom cruise could be tom cruise
crazy yeah he's kind of in his own
uh he's kind of in his own category i
guess
uh cheryl says i rewatched the filth and
the fury it's great i know i was you
know what i meant to re-watch it for the
show i watched a bunch of other ones
because i was kind of trying to focus
more on
um you know in the limited time i had i
was trying to focus more on the murder
and kind of the aftermath and like sid's
death and everything so i watched a lot
of ones about that like i watched like
who killed nancy in like the last 24
about sid vicious like you know your
last 24 hours and that that was like a
british one and stuff like that but
i actually wouldn't mind re-watching
filth and the fury at some point
uh bordello blood was filmed in my
hometown sorry british
columbia
all right yeah that was right before
miller went full [ __ ]
you never go full [ __ ] and like i
said he was i think he was less annoying
in the 90s just because
it i mean
it was a kind of a newer shtick back
then and nobody else was really doing
that
and
but a little bit of it went a long way
you know and i have to say i was super
into
i know this is weird but i was super
into stand-up comedy in the 90s
um like late 80s early 90s so i knew
like all the comedians and i didn't
really get to see any of them live
the only
the only comedian i ever gonna see live
was gallagher and i didn't even do that
on purpose because
somebody where i worked had tickets for
it and they couldn't use them and
they're like hey you want to go see
gallagher for free and i was just kind
of like i guess why not
because i'd seen his specials and stuff
but i have to say because gallagher in
case you guys don't know he's the one
that like smashed all the food at the
end
and even though i was up in the
balcony
um
i didn't anticipate
how much that place would stink
from all of the food that he smashed
and it was so bad that even up in the
balcony of like a a large theater
it was making me gag like the smell was
making me gag and i had to like leave
and like go sit in the bathroom no but i
mean it was the thing is he smashes like
all these different kinds of food it's
all like a different a bunch of
different kinds yeah so like the
combination
of all of it just like made this
horrible
stench i tried to watch one of his shows
it was on television one time i just
couldn't get through it it just i i just
wasn't funny
it's like just not there was a couple
that were kind of funny like back in the
80s but it's just not funny it's not
yeah like nowadays it's not really just
he's just and people are laughing like
this shit's hilarious and i'm like what
is what is funny i mean everybody's
sense of humor is different i get that
and we've talked about this before but
comedy doesn't it usually doesn't age
well yeah um
i tend to like honestly i tended to like
and even now like if i like a comedian i
tend to like ones that don't tell jokes
i tend to like ones that just tell
stories that are like funny stories you
know what i mean um you know that's why
i like like eddie izzard and stuff like
that and he does a lot of improv
and he just kind of talks about funny
situations that kind of you know get
more and more absurd and that's funny um
back in the 90s i liked uh jake johansen
a lot i don't know what happened to him
he was hilarious but he was kind of
another thing where he was
would talk about like just situations
that were funny rather than like telling
jokes with a punch line i mean there's
an art to that too but
to me that's funnier like just
more observational kind of [ __ ]
which is funny because i just for
whatever reason i was bored the other
day and i just needed uh to kill some
time so i pulled this book out and i've
read this like a million times but i was
like reading it again
but uh this this book here which is
called me talk pretty one day by david
sedaris um
and i pulled it out it's like funny
essays where he like talks about
his life and uh
this book is one of the [ __ ] funniest
things i've ever read and it still is i
haven't read it for a few years but i
was rereading it like the other day i'm
like yep still [ __ ] hilarious
especially the [ __ ] where
he moves to france
uh because his boyfriend has a house in
normandy so he goes over there and i'm
at the section now where he's
trying to learn to speak french because
he's living over there so he takes this
class and just like oh my god it's like
so [ __ ] funny all this stuff about
him being in france is hilarious and
oracle said pat and oswalt is funny in
that way too yeah i always found him
like really funny also
tammy said i was lucky and got to see
eddie izzard three times oh yeah thank
you i always wanted to i always wanted
to see him i did
but i don't know if i'm ever gonna get
to but he's honestly nowadays
and i don't even know if he i mean he
still does stand up right i kind of feel
like he was doing more acting
and you know he runs marathons and does
[ __ ] like that nowadays too but
i was the
i always wanted to see him and i just
never even got to i never got to but
he's like super funny
um oh [ __ ] taylor just showed up oh [ __ ]
tina you go maybe put my eye patch back
on
let me put my eye patch on i know what
that does to that woman
do you i know what that does that way
okay
here we go
tobacco
danny rowling says i just got my cat for
her first birthday
a remote control
rat car
okay so it's a remote control card that
looks like a rat
oh for cats from amazon for twenty
dollars and she loves it
i wonder if pookie would like that we
probably should just do it in the
bathroom so because i don't think it
would go over the
over the uh carpet would it i hear you
all in there baiting me to say something
about them [ __ ] russian [ __ ]
i don't respond to vague
[ __ ] comments i can only respond to
direct questions because
most y'all don't know anything what
you're talking about you don't have any
men you don't have any
military experience
so and you're just seeing things on
television
and
responding
to them
based on the way that they want you to
respond to it
almost everything is propaganda
um but uh
i don't care really what anybody you
know and putin doesn't care what you
think about him he's gonna do what he
wants to do what he thinks is best for
his country
that's that's really what it all boils
down to
he saw a weakness
and people kept pissing him off
so he he handled his business
and just like what me and granters were
saying before there will be no response
there's no there's no way to respond to
this
that's if there was a way to respond he
wouldn't have done it
you're not dealing with iraq
all right this is [ __ ] russia
they think this [ __ ] out
50 moves down the [ __ ]
way
they know every possible response that
we have and they have a counter measure
for that
they don't give a [ __ ] about those
sanctions they're going to use those
sanctions to make themselves stronger
the intent
is to make russia a dominant superpower
on the planet and got a real good chance
of it very good
success breeds success
when you punk out super powers
you take their success away it's it's
it's not a science it's a game
so
and it's a game the west is going to
lose
eventually
senor stix says will tom and jenny ever
see kiss in concert uh i would know no
i mean i have limited money and uh
that's definitely not even in my top 100
probably not even in my top 1000 to be
honest with you
uh oscar says the confederate
confederacy of dunces is the funniest
book ever written yeah it's up there
that is a pretty hilarious book uh it's
been a while since i've read it but yeah
i remember it being super funny you know
what honestly one of the funniest things
i ever read
um
was oscar wilde's the importance of
being earnest like the play i remember
reading that when i was maybe in my late
teens or early 20s and just laughing my
ass off i thought that was like one of
the funniest things i ever read i don't
know if i would still think it was funny
that might hit me different now
but i remember thinking that was like
[ __ ] hilarious like the first time i
read it
um yeah so we're talking about the rc
car it works good on carpet big off-road
tires okay so i guess they did like
think about that
i have thought about getting her
i have i didn't get her a lot of like
mechanical toys she does have this one
thing that's like a ball
and you turn on the thing and it has a
battery in it and it has like a little
thing that sticks out the top and it's
got like a little tail
deal on it and it spins around and
mostly she just kind of like looks at it
and then she reaches up and grabs the
tail and then it stops and then she's
just like okay i'm bored so there's that
um i got her one of those
things that's like it's like four layers
and it's got like uh what are they
they're like little tunnel things and
they have balls in them
and so she can like go in there like hit
the stuff with the little different
colored balls but the weird thing about
that is that she won't play with it if
you're looking at her
she only plays with it if you're in the
other room
and then like you peek around the corner
and she's playing with it and then she
looks up like she's not supposed to be
playing with it like she's in trouble
i'm not entirely sure why she thinks
that with that one toy
i think i don't know she thinks it's
like not hers i gave it to her for
christmas
but she acts like
because i hear her playing with it in
the middle of the night because it makes
a pretty distinctive noise and then i go
in there and i peek around the corner
i'm like you playing with the toy and
she's like i was i wasn't i wasn't
playing with it and she acts like i
don't know it's like the weirdest thing
ever she still looks so strange
so strange
no business laughing says that i didn't
think that they would invade now
grampur's is my witness we talked about
it right here on the show before it
happened that if
an invasion took place
that uh there would be no response
they'd get away with it
um
i knew that they'd do something but man
i was impressed that that mission was a
great mission attacked from three
different sides
one of them was an amphibious landing
that was [ __ ] pretty complicated that
was better than [ __ ]
what we did when we went into
into kuwait
or your liberation in kuwait about like
that
but everybody's all upset because of the
propaganda like it's an invasion and
they're going to occupy and i don't
think they will i don't think they can
i think they're in there to look at some
bio weapons facilities that are there
get some evidence and then they'll
probably pull out i don't think they'll
be there longer in a couple months
they don't want to they don't want to be
in ukraine they want ukraine to be
vacant as a buffer zone
because if they occupy it then all of a
sudden nato has missiles on its borders
they just want to
they said they wanted to denazify
ukraine
and to get some of the corruption that
was out of there and they were [ __ ]
making
biological weapons on their border
in seven different facilities
just so they won't tell you that because
we were financing it
all right
we were doing bad [ __ ] in there
you're gonna find out about it
there's this knee jerk reaction that
we're the good guys we're not the good
guys
we haven't been the good guys in a long
time
tila says what's the best book that
needs to be made into a movie asap so
[ __ ] many
uh that i can't really
honestly i just read one yesterday
and i reviewed it it's not going up for
a couple weeks
like the review
but i'm not entirely sure why it was
never made it actually was optioned but
i don't think they ever made it and this
is author graham joyce his name is he
was a british author he died um back in
2014 and he wrote a [ __ ] ton of books
and they optioned a lot of them for
movies but so far they haven't made any
of them yet but the one that i read
which was called the tooth fairy i was
kind of like
why do i don't understand why they
wouldn't make this into a [ __ ] movie
it would be really really good i think i
mean they did make a movie called the
tooth fairy in 2006 but it wasn't
anything to do with the book it was
completely different uh dj maniac says
coming this summer the importance of
being ernest p worrell starring john
cena's jim barney uh yeah that was good
who would uh tom and jenny see live in
concert that they have not who is still
alive says senor stix
um i still want to see nick cave because
i never got to
uh so that's a bummer
um
i would have said the fall but marky
smith died a few years ago so i can't
see them anymore
they never came to florida i don't think
the closest they ever came was atlanta
and i couldn't afford to go and that was
like many years ago
um but yeah nick cave honestly i
wouldn't mind seeing duran duran
although i wish that i had seen them
back in the 80s
um
or 90s that'd be fine too i mean they
still look good and they still sound
good and stuff they're you know they're
still they're not that old
but i kind of wish i'd seen them back in
the day yeah i've never seen duran ram
no i haven't either i've seen most uh
i've seen most of the other bands i'm
into
they're kind of chilled out though now
you know they're they're older than they
were well aren't we all yeah that's what
i mean but they're still they still like
look they still look pretty good though
yeah i think for their they weren't
pounding themselves in the ground like
billy idol
even though billy idol [ __ ] he kept
it together for a long time he did yeah
um
i'm actually shocked with all the [ __ ]
he went through like that he still looks
as good as he does yeah
not all natural but
well that's his hair i think that's a
[ __ ] wig
but it's hey i'd be the same way you do
what you got to do you know i'd be the
same way when you're famous yeah when
you're famous but the uh
he came up with a new album and there's
a [ __ ] he's got he's got a song on
there called uh bitter taste it's
[ __ ] badass it's like as good as
chris isaac kind of reminds me of chris
isaac's song what was that uh
perfect wicked what's called wicked game
yeah it reminds me of that kinda good
real good
i like that he picked a more kind of
mature
theme
you know i mean kind of like an
age-appropriate sound
yeah i mean that's the thing you really
kind of do have to go more in that
direction when you get older because
it's like you can't be out there i'm
talking about snoring [ __ ] i mean you
can snort and coke off
[ __ ] back in the 80s everyone's just
gonna be like
you know what i made yeah
uh camp guy says 1984 brave new world
would be good movies to make or remake
um
honestly i don't think i've i mean there
was a good adaptation of 1984
with john hurt
but
i don't think i mean i know they've done
an adaptation of brave new world but i
don't remember if it was any good or not
i do kind of feel like maybe
that seems like i'm surprised that the
version of that hasn't been done more
recently unless it has and i just didn't
hear about it that's the thing it's
there's so many streaming services and
there's so many like independent
filmmakers and there's so many things so
i mean it's very possible that somebody
could have made
uh you know an adaptation of something
that i totally didn't even know about
because i've had that happen where
i've read a book by like a horror author
and i was just kind of like oh man this
is cool like why didn't i ever hear
about this author before and then i
found out that find out that like two or
three of their books have already been
made into movies it's just that they
weren't real
big or i didn't hear about them so if
that does happen grampus asked me when
when is the tiger dragon gonna invade
america and mexico okay
you guys don't know what he's talking
about well i called it tiger dragon
there's now a chinese russian alliance
and it has to do with currency
because the currency markets are [ __ ]
real
people think that
money's worth something money's not
worth anything if you have guns to back
it up with
us dollar was a world reserve currency
for really only one reason we have a
badass navy that was insuring the oil
shipments
as soon as america is not the premier
navy
or not the premier military in the world
this currency will collapse and they
know that
the billionaires involved in it don't
care they'll move to another currency
because they have hard assets
so
russia knew that it's going to get cut
out of the uh of the european banking
cartel system who gives a [ __ ]
cryptocurrency is gonna be the future
uh that's why they're trying to stop it
if cryptocurrency was no threat to them
they wouldn't be trying to regulate
crypto
there's only two sources of power
the power to spin narrative or the and
the power to print currency
when you lose that power you're gone
and the old dinosaur [ __ ] apparatus
that's been running the show for the
past two three four hundred years is on
its way out it's technologically
obsolete
so they know they're going to lose their
power they have to ensure the power of
their [ __ ] children and their
grandchildren so they're trying to usher
in
the last gasp which is a social credit
score if you have that
you can force people to use the currency
and you can force people to use the the
news media that they want you to use to
maintain power
that shit's going
they know it's going to fall apart
china and russia are starting to team up
and some people are calling it the tiger
dragon
okay
the tiger dragon will win because it's
new money they don't have these old
oligarch families they have to watch out
for the corruption isn't as deep into
them they can make decisions on a dime
they can take a risk and go into things
like cryptocurrencies
uh and it will work those two together
they'd get that to work they will kick
the west's ass
what's happened to the west is we've
we've had some successes in the second
world war and [ __ ] kicked back and
got fat and [ __ ] lazy and got
permissive
and soft
all right the russians are white people
but they're ghetto all right and they're
they're hungry
and their their leadership
has 140 iq leadership and they're
military-backed
our [ __ ] leaders are [ __ ] all
right they're soft rich boys rich kids
fake [ __ ] people who just won
elections they're not specialists in any
of this
russia and china are weaponized they're
they're they're their command structure
is military
and they're about winning they don't
care about what's right or wrong it's
just winning and that always wins if you
look at history
so our system's gonna crumble but it'll
be replaced with something like theirs
but more western it's just gonna we're
in a time of transition
um
but uh tiger dragon when will tiger
dragon invade they won't because if you
look russia does not need land it's got
a [ __ ] ton of it and same with china
the last thing that they would ever want
to do is to act like stupid-ass
americans and try to get involved in any
foreign affairs and take land and expand
they don't need to
they're just going to perfect what they
have
now some chinese generals in the past
said some crazy [ __ ] they would release
pandemics and plagues to wipe out
everything on the on the north and south
american continents so they could come
in and [ __ ]
populate it
see
the chinese version of history is that
the north america belongs to them they
said that they were here first
and there is some
evidence that that might have been true
there's a bunch of anchors off the coast
of damn california
that looked to be coming from the middle
ages like you know maybe around year
[ __ ] 1200 1300 there may have been
chinese here long ago they had a real
bad ass steam-powered navy long long
back in the 1400s or 1400s so they could
have been here
they see this as as their land
all right at least
nationalist chinese in the ccp back in
beijing
and they had no problem about wiping out
people and taking land that's that's
what they do
you know they they
they don't have any moral problems with
killing enemies you're supposed to kill
enemies you're supposed to make friends
with them if you make friends with an
enemy then how's housing an enemy it's
not an enemy
we're trapped up in a western bubble
other people don't think that way
we just don't
so uh but no they wouldn't come here
uh i don't it would be a waste of time
they're the those are big countries they
don't need land
that's that i answered this question
uh tila says jenny's face right now yeah
well you know she's not interested in
either well no it's not that it's just
that i like to uh you know the friday
night shows are supposed to be fun and i
try to keep things fun
and then i'm also trying to like answer
questions
and then i get way way behind uh you
know so so it's that
i'm just trying to keep everything fun a
lot of people come here to like avoid
that kind of [ __ ] okay uh which i also
do so
you know what i mean uh oscar says jenny
you guys have to see the cursed great
new werewolf movie that hit theaters
i've heard a lot of good about that so
god we haven't we still have that
[ __ ] uh amc stubs thing
but we haven't been to the movies
months and months i think the new batman
came out today did it i thought it
wasn't coming out till march
or like early march that dude said it
came out today
maybe it did i can't remember i i
thought that it was like next week okay
like for like the first friday in march
but i could be wrong about that i don't
really remember a guy subscribed to
posted something yesterday he said it
was coming out this friday
maybe yeah but maybe he met like next
friday okay like not today friday
because today's friday yeah maybe what
was yesterday you said friday oh okay
maybe it did i don't know like i said i
thought somebody said like early march
but i don't even remember
um let's see
batman's next week okay he must have his
time okay see i was right okay we need
more uh werewolf movies yeah i mean
well we need more good ones holy [ __ ]
you guys i was watching
i got on a rifftrax tear last night
and they have a lot of them actually on
amazon prime that you can watch for free
and they have this one called
speaking of werewolves called lycan
colony
now
this movie
i mean you think you've seen some bad
movies
you think you've seen you know you've
seen birdemic
you've seen that kind of stuff
this movie i think was several steps
down from that
it honestly looked like
they it i mean clearly they shot it with
some piece of [ __ ] camera or a piece of
[ __ ] phone they didn't have any like any
microphone they were just using whatever
microphone their shitty phone had uh
because she couldn't hear anything that
anybody was saying because it was super
tiny and
the shots were just kind of like i mean
i can't even explain to you like how bad
it was but
holy crap it was so so entertaining
and i don't even i think i fell asleep
at some point so i don't even know what
the [ __ ] was going on in it but
they couldn't even have when somebody
got attacked by a werewolf
somebody would get attacked by a
werewolf and it was just like they'd
kind of like push them and then they
would put like in
i'm presuming in after effects or
whatever uh you know program they were
using they would put like a cartoon
blood spray
and that was supposed to be
i mean
i think it was made in like the 90s
oscar says dog soldiers is a masterpiece
yeah i really really like dog soldiers
that's honestly like one of my favorite
uh werewolf movies
um cheryl says so bad it's good yeah i
mean
it kind of like it kind of
it's funny because it was on rift tracks
but
in another way i'm just kind of like the
people that made this movie and i feel
like it was kind of like a family type
of thing because a lot of the people
that were in the movie and on the crew
like had the same last name so i'm
assuming that it was like a family and
their friends which you know that's cool
i'm not [ __ ] on people that want to
make movies and maybe they're not all
that talented at it
you know but whatever uh
but
i mean some of the stuff in this was
just so
basic
that you would think that anybody
especially now and like i said maybe
this you know this came out years ago i
kind of feel like it was maybe mid to
late 90s
but
i think even back then
i mean even if you were like a low
budget filmmaker you would know like not
to do this stuff like there was one
scene where they were talking to this
one woman and she was in a kitchen
talking about something and she was like
cutting up vegetables or whatnot and the
shot of her
there were like pots hanging from the
ceiling and they were like in front of
her face
you know what i mean and i'm like duh
all you have to do is like move around
so you can actually see her face
and like hear her talking but it's like
they couldn't even manage that
you know what i mean uh sure uh hugo is
asking have you seen in the company of
wolves yeah that's a good one too i
think i reviewed that one uh not too
long ago actually
uh what's the best werewolf movie
um
american werewolf in london or yeah
no or the howling
the original hauling yeah the other ones
that was not that good well it's weird
because a long time ago
like uh howling too your sister is a
werewolf which i [ __ ] love that uh
that subtitle by the way i remember
seeing that a bunch like on cable
back in the old days and thinking it was
okay
and then i went to watch it recently
like like a year ago or something and
i'm like wow this is like unwatchable it
was so so [ __ ] bad
um uh let's see
let me in is great
uh are you talking about like let the
right one in that's a vampire movie
though that's not uh that's not a
werewolf movie and honestly uh that's
one where you know because let the right
one in was uh what was that swedish
norwegian dane what the [ __ ] was it i
can't remember now but um
yeah so there was that but they did an
american version of it and that was
actually one case where the american
version was actually pretty [ __ ]
decent it's not as good as the original
but it was still pretty decent
uh yeah and the company of wolves was
awesome
the one with oliver reed
wait what
a wolf in that was another one that i
wanted to see because i already see it i
saw that a bunch like back in the early
80s it was on
uh
yeah it was on hbo all the time and i
remember really really liking it
oh and ginger snaps yeah that's another
good one yeah it's good yeah it's good
that was a good one i like that it's
canadian though that is canadian well
that doesn't mean
it's canadian though
it's actually kind of the second best
one i had like cute girls and good story
and the fashion was right for the for
the late 90s
you know i mean that's the way we were
dressing back then
it's kind of good
that was kind of like the 90s
late 90s goth interpretation of
werewolves
it's funny because i kind of feel like
until gingersnaps came out
it really seemed it seemed strange that
it never really occurred to anybody
to make a werewolf movie that i know of
that was tied to
girls menstrual cycles because it seems
like an obvious
it seems like an obvious uh story line
and so it just
i mean i guess it just goes to show like
for a long time with a sausage fest like
all that stuff was like they didn't even
think about it tila is asking what
rawhead rex was rawhead rex was a
magical honky okay that's what it was it
was an irish [ __ ] monkey demon
he's a honky dude
it was it was it was supposed to be a
medieval
demonic irish warlord that had somehow
been buried underneath the damn
uh [ __ ]
stone
block
and both the lightning had i don't
remember exactly how it happened both
the lightning came down they saw it and
it fell over it hit the stone and
somebody knocked it over in the field
and it released it it was the whole
thing and it's just a giant
demon honky this is white dude with a
[ __ ] mohawk and leather
armor and he was [ __ ] huge and his
head was [ __ ] like the size of a
[ __ ] horse looked like a big old
neanderthal
with big old bug eyes
and it was like one of the worst
one of the worst monsters
of that era it's so good
real goo
but the thing is we loved it we still
loved it it it looked fake as [ __ ]
but we were just laughing and going yeah
it was kind of like a
i guess it was about eight nine feet
tall it was wearing black leather armor
and it looked like a big old [ __ ]
neanderthal [ __ ] white dude with a
mohawk what the [ __ ] a black mohawk with
[ __ ] horse teeth and big old rounds
you liked it
you don't liked it you'd have married it
no one knowing you
she saw it she said you put it right she
said that big old husband of yours they
matched
i have to say it's well it's a shame
because
i'm like i'm a big fan of clive barker's
work all together like his writing his
art everything
and it bums me out that they haven't
made like a great move i mean hellraiser
is pretty great but that they haven't
made just like a great adaptation
of some of his stuff because it seems
like his stuff is so imaginative
that you kind of need like a you know a
300 million dollar budget to make this
[ __ ] look good if you're gonna do raw
head rex which actually shutter just
added it in their folk horror category
because it is a folk horror movie yeah
but tila says she would have tamed it
she jumped on that [ __ ] and just
flicking right
but the thing about it is like you're
really kind of like undercutting
you know the thing
if that monster came lumbering at you i
mean you're just gonna be like
yeah wait a minute wait a minute wait
you're gonna eat me okay
it's like you would just laugh and laugh
it was an irish movie if i remember
correctly wasn't it yeah it was an irish
movie
it was not a bad movie i think i think
tila said she liked the movie it was it
was it's a good movie it's just the
monster looks stupid the monster that
was really the monster
the monster was not animated it needed
to have an animatronic
head
um
so it had a face
it would have actually been better if it
had a speaking role
but they couldn't do that because his
head didn't move his face didn't move
right yeah there's just kind of a guy
going like yeah
with a halloween right they needed to
have three or four of them for different
kinds of shots so you could string it
all together to make
to make the to make raw head a character
and it would have been a lot better
uh but i appreciated the movie we we
loved it as kid [ __ ] grabbed us it
was our witness man [ __ ]
me
steve rouse and [ __ ] jason quinlan
watched that [ __ ] and we [ __ ] liked
it so much i think we watched it
we rented it again
the the week after that
watched that we saw it at [ __ ]
steve's house
we liked it
we were laughing at it there was a
couple things that really stood out
for some reason i don't really know why
the [ __ ] stained glass window
with that
in the church
that included [ __ ] raw head
underneath the ground i think was it
underneath the ground with a cross on
top of him or something yeah and a
little light on the ground god damn we
put a cross
yeah yeah somehow light came through it
at a certain time and didn't it shown
shine a beam kind of like and it's ready
there's a lost ark to tell you where to
to where to go through the wall i mean i
can't remember something like that
i remember i remember that stained glass
window that
and that priest going on his knees in
front of it he was a follower of [ __ ]
raw head the catholic priest irish
catholic priest and he's he he helped he
was waiting for rex to come back from
the grave and he's [ __ ] down on his
knees and [ __ ] tears his robe open
like that and he goes baptized me and
that big old thing was pissing on him
and that blew our minds man his
teenagers like man he baptized him with
[ __ ] demon piss and he's liking it
[ __ ] man there's water sports in the
[ __ ] movie demonic wow demonic
homosexual water sports and it was a
priest
we our minds were [ __ ] blown man
imagine if you had read some of clyde
barker's stuff yeah your minds would
really be blown yeah because man there
was all kinds of yeah we didn't reach
there was all kind of perverse
it was perfect
um they just needed to they just needed
to fix that monster's face that's what i
said that's why i kind of think that a
lot of uh movie adaptations of his stuff
yeah are not as good because like i said
one his stuff is so imaginative and his
stuff is so perverse
that a lot of the stuff
you know they couldn't really put in a
movie
and
you can't really cheap out on it either
to be honest i would have all i always
wanted to see
a movie adaptation of that short story
that he wrote what's it called uh in the
hills the cities about the two cities
and the entire populations of them would
all strap themselves together into these
big huge like behemoth monsters and they
would fight each other
and just like the description of it was
so [ __ ] awesome and that i was just
kind of like oh my god they should
totally make that into a movie one day
tina say hell yeah tom i'll turn a demon
into my slave one two three that's right
hey man that [ __ ] booty can do that
to it not only man but man and demon it
can happen to him just whip it whipping
him
granthar says is it true that witches
who practice santeria put their
menstrual fluids in a drink and give it
to a man they want to captivate and
seduce i have heard that before um you
know i've i've read like old not just
santeria but anything that's like from
old like witchcraft texts and stuff like
that i don't know if anybody actually
did that but it was written down in a
lot of like really old books from that
time period that that was one way to do
it so
you know they did that in mid-summer as
well
didn't she put me yeah she put menstrual
blood in that one guys yeah drink
but looks like kanavasan just showed up
i don't see him i think people talk
there he is what's up car
thank you zach hey guys i'm
decompressing from work what end of the
world rants from tom did i miss oh don't
listen
let's not revisit that
she gets mad when i tell the truth
no i just get bad when you go on and on
and i'm just trying to like keep things
light and fun and you just kind of go on
and on about stuff like everyone's sick
of hearing about that's all okay mike
says never seen someone in their 50s so
jacked so guess they're talking about
you
i just don't think they're talking about
me
don't think it's natural bro
[Laughter]
hrt and all kinds of other stuff lots of
work and [ __ ] lots of [ __ ]
you know wizardry
hard work
uh somebody was oh i was gonna say
something man [ __ ] it cod of ocelot all
right
i've known khan for [ __ ] years we
we've talked about the show we talk off
the show and uh you know
like we talk about family and [ __ ]
geopolitics and culture
but
me me being a white hispanic and having
a latin american background
i get i try to resist it you know what i
mean but [ __ ] he does he
khan does this thing where he shows me
these
photographs of these latin women's asses
and there'd be like a sh in a shot to be
three of them
and he's like which one
he's trying to get me to [ __ ] choose
and
and it's like
it's just something i don't understand
what it is but latin american dudes do
this
it's like
they they check another man's
functioning ability to see if he agree
if he is attracted to the same booty as
you're attracted so then you they want
you it's like appreciating fine art they
he wants me to write down a whole
uh analysis of boudiology okay
that's not your field though your field
is boob booboology but it's it's i have
to go into another specialty though
the lab minor in booty ology i'm a minor
in booty
in brazil you you automatically growing
up in brazil you automatically at least
are minoring in buddhiology because
that's just a booty-centric world
central and south america is
booty-centric
that's the women
they just they're the they're the
mistresses of booty they work on booty
constantly
booty science
how big the booty the shape of the booty
they're working on the booty injecting
things into the booty
and it's just you know then you know
that the girls will be flat chested but
they have a [ __ ] fantastic booty
although brazil's [ __ ] they've
discovered implants they like that too
they try to balance it out to get that
that hourglass shape so it is
starting to you know
in recent decades it is it is kind of
becoming a little bit more like america
but there was a while you know in our
culture
in the 80s even into the 90s
where a girl if she had a booty then she
wasn't considered to be attractive
crazy
crazy
j-lo broke that mold though
yeah jlo educated the white man on booty
at least of my generation
and then that they go oh that's right i
guess i guess booties do exist
that was the yeah that was the who would
have thought
yes who'da thought
i mean you need a booty you need
something to sit on it's got to be
something there
yeah
yeah i don't want the physiology you
know sure yeah uh oscar says you guys
should do a review of the lodge i think
we already did because we saw that in
the theater so i'm pretty sure we did a
review of it i liked it i don't think
tom liked it uh taylor said they would
probably remake rawhead eventually with
a better looking monster i kind of wish
they would honestly to be uh to be
honest
of all the clyde barker stuff
i kind of wish they would do a movie
adaptation of weave world but you'd have
to have a big budget to do that [ __ ]
because that's some crazy ass [ __ ] but i
would actually really really like to see
that honestly i liked some of his more
down-to-earth stuff too like cold heart
canyon like i thought that was really
good as well
uh mike also said got the feeling tom
got into goth for the goth girl [ __ ]
probably
um
that was just in the
i got witnesses that went to high school
with me right here
it was
oh there's a lot of factors one of the
factors was
is uh me and granthars he ended up being
in the police i ended up having a
military career and also doing other
weird things in the contract world but
um
the the uh i did some sideways [ __ ] okay
and uh anyway
the um
we met each other in the high school
drama program
okay
and uh singing musicals and stuff so we
were constantly around
what we call punk rock girls
not all the punk rock girls were in the
in the uh drama
program but a lot of them were and
i guess i want to call them our friends
were these punk rock girls and we would
hang out in the
you know in the [ __ ] cafe you know
with our cafe back then those days
daddy's
and go [ __ ] go to the drive-ins and
[ __ ] party and
park and [ __ ] and
this isn't when i was in michigan though
i did part of my high school time in
michigan part of it in brazil
but uh
uh no so we we grew up with it
and
goth was kind of evolving at that time
and then i was old enough to go to clubs
and that's really where it started
okay
uh thank you david june this is going
back holy because i'm behind uh tom can
you creep out my male roommate he's one
of my oldest friends btk in bondage
whatever you want to do creep this kid
out his name is logan
[Laughter]
let him think about something he's got
to come up with some
tila says uh yeah jenny many ladies in
new orleans used to add menstrual blood
to spaghetti sauce etc yeah that's okay
that's gross
i know you
i know you're hanging out with this guy
over there
out you're over his place
but i just want you to know that the
lord is with you
[Laughter]
don't be tempted by another man's booty
i know that i'm here i'm locked up be
here for the rest of my life uh
i'll never get you know
on top of the world like i was back when
i was with the church and being a good
good upstanding citizen
did you ever see my photo shoots i had
some really good photo shoots
[Laughter]
you're so pretty some people some people
you know thought they were
kind of kinky and yeah they were they
were kinky and um i get down to holes
and stuff and dressed up in clothing and
special clothes
take pictures of myself
no send them to the police
it was cool you want a photo i'll send
you a photo
will you sign it
send me some money to my account and
so i can get some stuff from the canteen
and
i'll buy a camera and i'll send some
photos
what do you get from the canteen dennis
cigarettes
orange yeah why i use those to trade
those for my house
okay
i thought you were gonna say you stuck
them up your urethra
that seemed like that wasn't
that's not really his scene i don't
smoke that was kind of
it's not happening well you don't need
to smoke to stickers
it's not healthy
who's that excuse them but i just use
them for money yeah let's use them for
money okay yeah who was um [ __ ] man who
was that i just totally like lot this is
what happens when you get old kids look
man they're sending all kinds of money i
know it's like like i said i keep
getting behind uh thank you mike
thank you no need for me too i have a
phd in booteology yeah
yeah
booty size it's booty science yeah there
we go
uh it's menstrual blood spaghetti sauce
in the cookbook no much but you know
what if we do a second one i'll do that
don't think that there's probably not in
the world somewhere a cookbook that is
menstrual blood centric
because i know
that there is i don't know if there's a
whole cookbook but there is um one
that's like uses like afterbirth not
after birth but what do you call that
thing that the baby's in
the placenta yeah there you go i can't
remember words anymore you guys but uh
yeah so i know that there's some
i don't know if there's a whole cookbook
but i have seen like recipes for like
using the placenta which is pretty gross
but you know whatever
i'm not eating it so thorn says tom
needs a youtube where he discusses
military stuff and world events he
clarifies questions i had about what's
happening you see that's why i thought
that you
took my you took my laptop so you could
do your you do a show maybe well yeah i
might be able to even do it through my
my uh thing here once i get unlimited i
got to upgrade this to like unlimited
data
and i'll be able to stream for my my
thing
because i got i can put this on that
tripod that i have
and i'll take that into my cave with all
my equipment yeah it does look cuz
that's what i mean if that's what i
thought you were setting that room up
for all right look
i've been through a bunch of these
[ __ ] wars my first one was the first
gulf war
and i would [ __ ]
be doing stuff up in north carol up up
on the dmz near north korea [ __ ] camp
graves all right
during the first gulf war
we were doing the [ __ ] dmz mission
and what i'd go back to the barracks and
watch [ __ ] cnn
and
see what they were telling civilians
about what was really happening it was
all [ __ ] hype all right
the uh uh civilian news agencies won
they're [ __ ] paid for they're
especially the american ones the intel
agencies are paying them and rich people
are paying them to sell certain
narratives
the more they scare you the the better
their ratings are gonna be and it also
kind of helps the [ __ ] political
industry helping getting people elected
and
it's
the information you're gonna you're
getting through them is
[ __ ] is [ __ ] and um
concepts and ideas that would um
that would really wouldn't bother a
professional soldier would scare the
hell out of a [ __ ] civilian
because the concepts are very alien and
they seem alien and scary and immoral oh
my god you know especially today
but when you're out there doing it it's
just
[ __ ] it's more just work you know
and they're they're hyping it for effect
and ratings
what's happening now is not scary
it's the normal course of evolution of
societies and civilizations they rise
fall they're replaced new ones come new
players come and go you reap what you
sow
if you [ __ ] keep sewing failure and
weakness you reap [ __ ] weakness and
failure you keep sewing strength and
[ __ ] and
and [ __ ] victory you will reap
success
oh [ __ ] you rarely walk over the cat no
she ran into her leg right i was trying
to walk around her and she just like ran
into my shin like a weirdo come here
there's no order and there's no rules
that's another thing there's no order no
rules it happens because they want it
that way or they tell you to think the
way they want and rules are only for you
because you're poor the people that are
running the show they don't have any
rules they do whatever then they spin a
narrative before or after depending on
what [ __ ] little scam they're gonna
pull
pookie come here
i didn't mean to do that
i was coming out of the bathroom and she
was like running at me like that and i
tried to walk around her and then she
just like went like ran right in my leg
poor little thing
yeah now she's mad she's like mommy
kicked me
yeah oh baby girl uh khan i'm not
allowed to talk about it i talked about
it earlier so you can watch it after the
epic show
not allowed to talk about it well it's
just kind of like well it's her channel
so you know
i'm just saying yeah it's like i said i
like the friday night show because it's
fun but it's like you know what i mean
i kind of said it's not fun
it's not fun to talk about
uh but yeah so i probably need another
drink honestly i'll make you one hold on
just trying to catch it
yeah i got kind of behind yeah uh i
heard of shark blood in beer
still no thanks no are they still on the
thing where they think that sharks never
get cancer that was a long time ago i
heard that
uh so they were putting like sharks up
[ __ ] and everything cartilage
yeah
that's not true though sharks absolutely
do get cancer actually i think all
animals get cancer or almost all of them
do if they live long enough
so there's that
uh but yeah if you guys weren't here on
wednesday i think i mentioned it on
wednesday but
before i opened it
i'm showing this check this [ __ ]
fancy ass [ __ ] out
all right
that is sam's vodka all right this is
the sam's generic vodka you know what it
says on it it says
french vodka
so that's new because i don't remember
seeing that french vodka
yeah
so have we got this fancy ass bottle
there's no the the name is french
well you know that's all you need it's
[ __ ] fancy yeah that's what it means
i don't think we've got that kind before
that must be new i don't remember ever
seeing that there at sam's he just got
that last time he went to sam's and i
was like ooh
um let's see oh yeah what i was gonna
say was that
if you guys weren't here on wednesday i
brought up
what happened with pookie
is that she got into
the closet like in my dressing room and
was climbing over a box or something
like that and she fell
and hung and almost like hung herself
on one of my bras there was like a bra
that was like hanging on a hanger
and she i guess she fell and she fell
into it and that she couldn't get out
and
uh yeah so i was like freaking out and i
was like sitting here at my desk like
thankfully because it was early in the
morning but i heard like choking sounds
i was like
and i was like what the [ __ ] is that and
then i went in there and she was in
there and she was like
aren't you like that with the [ __ ] and
it's uh it was awful
so
uh so she can't go in the in the closet
anymore
and she the funny thing is that i kept
the closet now i close the closet off
and
this morning she was like bound to
determine that she wanted to get into
that [ __ ] closet for what she's like
scratching at the door and like looking
at me yelling like what the [ __ ] this is
usually open why can't i come in here
and i told her i was like you remember
what happened in there right and she's
like i don't care man that fraud is good
is it yeah that's real good well like i
said that was new right yeah
yeah bras are deadly they are
it didn't even occur to me i didn't even
i didn't even think i had any bras
hanging in there
so i don't know how that [ __ ]
happened but
it was just one of those things and then
i was started freaking out because i
said [ __ ] man what if she had done that
like when i was asleep and like i didn't
hear anything
um you know how [ __ ] horrible that
would have been
so yeah taylor said she was choking on
your bra yeah it went like i guess it
was hanging on like a hanger and she was
climbing over a box or i don't know what
the [ __ ] she was doing in there and she
fell and her neck like fell right into
the bra and she was like that and she
couldn't get out of it
and uh yeah and i was just like luckily
i heard her
yeah i'm talking about what happened to
you polk
yeah you're okay now though yeah i was
like flipping out so i was just kind of
like now i don't want to like leave her
alone you know what i mean who knows
what she'll get into i'm gonna have to
get um
child proof things for the
bathroom cabinets because she figured
out there's nothing in there that can
hurt her i don't think
but because there's not much in there
honestly i think all it's in that one is
kind of like a couple coffee canisters
and that's it maybe and maybe some like
foam things but
uh i still don't i don't know i don't
want to think about it so
but she figured out how to open those
so
she's kind of like i think i mentioned
on the show wednesday i was like jackson
galaxy says having a cat is like having
a toddler that can reach the ceiling
and
oh no her little thing is empty and
tom's not in here to fill it up she's
over there sitting by her little
her little uh dish and she's like
sitting there looking at it like there's
nothing on this like what the [ __ ] and
then she keeps looking over at me
oh baby all right i gotta go put some
treats on it because she's gonna like
flip out
okay i'm common i know
yeah i'm coming
okay there we go we're gonna put that on
there all right
yeah good with that or
are you thinking about it okay she's
thinking about it
yeah she was she was giving me that look
like why why isn't there anything on
here right now
pookie needs a glass cage like like i
know it's like i was just kind of
thinking
uh
you know
and uh tila says is she okay yeah she's
okay i was i was i was like uh flipping
out maybe she got tired of hearing tom's
rants
i know it's you know uh
i mean
it's weird because i never thought about
like i did think about
when we first moved in this house
the first thing i thought about weirdly
was that
uh because you know it's two stories and
we had never lived anywhere that was two
stories before
and
it has like uh
you know it is like at the top of the
stairs there's like a little bit of a
place where
there's just uh you know things you can
like kind of go in between and i was
thinking well i was like what if she can
fit through those slats and like fall
like down on the floor like under it's
you know and i so i kind of worried
about that so i do kind of like worry
about weird [ __ ] like that but i
seriously never
imagined
that she would get
partially strangled by a bra i mean
but then i have heard of them i have
heard of uh cats getting tangled in
uh blinds like you know the strings
throw them blind check that and stuff
pot and i gotta check see if the what's
in the what's in the crock pot
carnitas
oh okay oh i thought i heard something
banging earlier maybe it was somebody
knocking on the door i can't really
it's weird i can't really hear from up
here i can't hear the garage door
opening and closing and i can hear like
you know the garage door like
the door from the house into the garage
like slamming but
the front door not so much because
that's like far further over
but
um
did you show tom that video i got of him
on loop when the stream crashed no i was
like i meant to and it's like i forgot
about it and then uh they're talking
about collars yeah i was always like
real nervous like we have the breakaway
collars
but we only put them on we only put the
collars on pookie when she was outside
like if she at our old house when she
would go outside and like hang out in
the backyard because i just didn't want
the neighbors being like oh hey free cat
you know what i mean like i wanted
somebody to know that she was uh that's
she belonged to somebody
um but honestly since we've moved here
and she seems to have lost interest in
going outside which i'm really happy
about
um
then we don't put the
put the collar on her anymore and
honestly even the breakaway ones it's
still just like i don't know it just
makes me really nervous because i can
like think of all these horrible
scenarios
of you know her jumping over something
that getting caught and then like not
and you know and so that's what like
freaked me out so much about seeing her
like with the bra and luckily like i
said i heard her
choking so she was only like that for
you know probably less than a minute
because i found her
but
i just don't like to think about what
would have happened if that would happen
in the middle of the night and i didn't
hear it
uh you know that's i didn't want to
think about it i was just like flipping
out and like tom was like i'll be coming
out of the shower and he's like what the
what happened is she all right and i was
just kind of like yes yes
i was like poor kid and pookie was just
like why are you freaking out mama i'm
all right you know she was like not even
she wasn't even upset about it
and i think she didn't understand why i
was so upset it was like crying and
stuff
she was just like you're crazy mommy
poor pokey this guy has a couple hours
so it is actually an instant it's not
even like one of the other i didn't know
which one you ordered
man that is some strong ass vodka it's
good huh it is good but i was just
saying like compared to that first uh
glass that's pretty like it's pretty
strong
don't
what are you doing what's tom cooking
he's making uh carnitas
in the crock pot
oh look
destruction
yeah
tom got the instant pot yeah
i mean we're going to make all kind of
stuff with that
[Music]
you could cook a whole human hat in
there oh man what
okay i'm sorry that's that's just how i
do i'm a horror writer that's the first
thing i think of i think of everything
in terms of how many human heads can i
fit in this
pot
all right
all right
it looks that looks interesting
and then you gotta what about this
something to hold over okay
just gotta read the instructions cheryl
asked how long does a bottle of vodka
last in your house
um
depends
week and a half two weeks somewhere
around there
yeah but that's hers
yeah well sometimes we'll should drink
us and why yeah because he wants i mean
he usually drinks tequila but now
sometimes
uh but i do not drink tequila however
sometimes he will drink vodka
so if he's out of tequila he will drink
some of my vodka
however if i'm out of vodka i just go
without
i'll just drink water because i'm not
drinking tequila so all right but yeah
we don't um because we don't drink every
night we only drink
on the shows wednesday and friday
and every now and then yeah if we go out
we'll drink
and then sometimes we'll drink on like
saturday night but not usually much
we'll just have like one or two but we
don't usually like drink the rest so
that's not generic that's the real thing
huh
yeah well yeah i'm saying it's i don't
even know if it's generic or not but
that's what everybody calls it i kind of
feel like now everybody just calls it
generic it's almost kind of like it's
got to a point where it's just like
they're actually
it's not wasn't that yeah that's about
standard but i'm just saying that
there's i mean everybody just calls it
instant pot but there's like a lot of
other brands of it
uh
head stew
yeah stew and chili honestly we're
thinking about like
indian food that was what we were mainly
thinking of because we make a lot of
indian food although we haven't made
much since we got here
now you did make that thai curry that
was delicious like last week or
something like that you have made a
couple curries since we've been here but
i feel like we used to make
indian food all the time like every
couple of days like we always had a big
block of paneer in here and we'd make
like [ __ ]
uh
you know we'd make butter chicken we'd
make uh sauce in here which is my
favorite things
so you know it's that
uh zach says i can't tell which is more
nasty tequila vodka or honey flavored
whiskey well
this whole house was starting to smell
like carnitas
yeah i can smell it yeah and that's like
way way way downstairs yeah it's way
downstairs it's just quite there it
okay it's fine okay um
honestly the only one i don't i really
don't like tequila i mean i can stomach
it if it's mixed with some [ __ ] like if
it's a tequila sunrise and if it's not
that strong
i just don't really like the taste of
tequila
um
you know it's just not my favorite thing
uh but vodka is good i don't depending
on what kind it is i don't really like
it straight unless it's flavored
and even then it depends on what flavor
it is they used to i can't remember who
i don't know if anybody makes it anymore
but they used to have a long time ago
there used to be
a coffee flavored vodka
or espresso flavored
and
well i kind of figured that was going to
happen i mean
she's going to come and get it she tries
to apologize when i catch you
no no no no i'm still going to do
[Laughter]
same thing with chewing on the ends of
my antennas
my little walkie-talkie antennas she'll
try to nibble on it hey she's oh oh i'm
sorry i'm sorry she can't
resist
yeah she doesn't mean it yeah it's just
she really really likes to chew on [ __ ]
and she forgets she forgets yeah because
we have things that she is allowed to
chew on like i have you know i have chew
sticks i have other things that i don't
care if she chews on yeah or scratches
and she doesn't know the difference
between i mean we have like a cat tree
that has all kind of scratchy [ __ ] on it
she has like a little scratchy throne
she has all kind of scratchy things
those little mice i have these little
mac i'll show you guys
where is it get here cause i just she's
like why'd you take it these little
elsa sent us those
remember right around halloween she sent
us like a big box of like all these and
look it came with like like a little
yeah crinkly dracula
she likes these man she's like she came
running
if i throw one of these at her she can
grab it with a single hand yeah she goes
and then puts it on the ground attacks
it man if they had a kitty baseball team
she would totally be on it she can catch
that outfielder like watch watch just
watch it are you ready to catch it here
it comes
got it
she that was two paws that time but
sometimes she'll just go boom and catch
it then i told you she'll if no one's
around
she's kicking it she puts it on the
ground kicks it with her back legs and
looks at me i'm killing it you're so
funny good girl poop yeah
cat is a trip
and jenny if you guys don't know that
are new to the show jenny puts up little
videos of the [ __ ] that she's done over
the years she's [ __ ] funny i need to
start making some new ones well i'm
trying to clean out like all the old
ones i've done because i've been like a
million videos of her i have a videos of
her
when she was little
uh the one i posted a few days ago was
her because remember at the old place
she used to sometimes hide behind my
computer monitor and we wouldn't figure
out when she was really little and we
couldn't figure out where she was for
like the longest time
but she would like wiggle under there
and be like hey you know she's much
bigger now so she can't hide as well
cheryl in here
thorns in the comments section talking
about patron tequila
i get this from sam's
that's that's sam's silver
it comes with a cork and everything
and i cannot tell this from um patron
silver it tastes exactly the same
patron and milagro
silver there because those are both
similar
but this is 18 bucks for a fifth
that's it yeah
i mean sam's is the [ __ ] if you're gonna
get everybody if you're gonna get booze
yeah we don't we only go to sam's like
maybe once every two months or something
especially now because it's much farther
i mean there is a liquor store right up
the street that's i mean it's next to
the publix
uh so
if we don't feel like you know if we're
not making a sam's run obviously then we
just go to that liquor store so you're
gonna pay more but
you know what are you gonna do
uh victor says
does anyone remember takisa the tequila
beer from the late 90s i don't think i
ever had it but i do remember that like
i remember maybe like the advertising
campaign
says she's got these little those little
mice all over her apartment from from
her cats yes yeah they're uh yeah we we
have [ __ ] there's like seven or eight of
them there's like a big pile of mice
over here and then in the living room
down there there's a big pile of places
a bunch of these oh my god you guys if
you can if you have cats no it's mint oh
man that's right yeah which isn't the
same family as cat yeah they sell these
on chewy they probably sell them other
places too
um
i think they're like up two bucks each
or something or they come like on a
little card and every time they get
grubby really quick because beige loves
these and pookie also loves these they
pick them up in one hand and rub them
all over their face they go
yeah you'll find them on their back with
their feet up in the air with one with
that in one hand and they're like
rubbing it on their face
and it's and it's like they're rubbing
hard they're like one they're like god
damn it god damn it they're like that
it's like the funniest thing both the
cats will do that yeah so i have to keep
getting new ones because they you know
they play with them so much that they
get like all gross and dirty but it
looks like
when you see them but it's it's like
some kind of an addictive drug or
something
well like i said mint and catnip are in
the same family so they react to it like
in a similar way but it's just funny
because
the way pookie reacts to things that i'm
guessing are pleasurable but it's almost
like she's angry at it yeah
because she remember what i said was
like now i can't even like brush my hair
like a normal person anymore because
when she hears that brush come out of
the
you know when she hears the brush come
out of my thing over there
by the mirror like the little holder she
hears it and she comes running and she
jumps up on the sink and she's like
brush pookie's hair and i'm just kind of
like can i brush my hair and she's like
no first you have to like spend an hour
brushing pookie's hair but she won't let
you brush her hair
she wants you to just hold it there so
she can aggressively like rub her face
on it and bite it yeah and if you take
it away and like try to brush your hair
she's like oh no and then she jumps up
on your shoulders and it's like
like starts reaching we buy these little
meat
sheba meat sticks it's like a stick
looks like beef jerky sticks like like a
slim jim and she likes to tune him once
and she'll beg for him at the side of
the bed and she wants two at least a day
too
and you hold it you can't throw it on
the ground if she throw it on the ground
she'll get mad she'll run away and shake
she's like no that was what i wanted
yeah screw it
yeah you want to hold it like that and
she'll sit there and
lick on it first and then starting on
and it takes forever forever but some
kind of msr experience where she's
looking at you and she's none and
i don't know and then she'll eat it a
little by little until it's all gone
and there might be only that much of it
left and you throw it on the ground
she's like ah she gets mad you suck
well she has to have the it's the same
thing with the hairbrush yeah because
i've tried because i'm like look i can't
really i don't really have time to stand
there for an hour and like hold the
brush there so i've tried to like prop
it up somewhere so she can like rub on
it no it's not the same you have to hold
it right and you have to hold it at
different angles so she can rub on it
and if you stop she gets mad and like
start she's like
like why did you stop and she gets all
mad about it and like i said if i try to
brush my hair then she like starts
jumping up on my tries to jump on my
head and it's like no
so
she she has a whole little routine of
stuff that you have to do this is
talking about moscow mules and marina
mules i don't know what that is that is
that like a [ __ ] a black cow
i don't know what kind of drink that is
just near them i've heard of like a
moscow meal but i don't remember what's
in it
it's gonna be
[ __ ]
vodka well yeah and a mule
gonna be some kind of a
chocolatey type flavor maybe something
that's what i i thought yeah i thought
it was kind of like that type of thing
cheryl says cheryl says i can't do gin
or gross ass cinnamon whiskey yeah i
don't like anything i don't like uh
goldschlager anything like that it gives
me horrible heartburn i can do
goldschlager even though i love
cinnamon yeah in general like i love
cinnamon toast i love cinnamon in things
but cinnamon flavored
liquors or liqueurs or anything like
that i can't do that it just gives you
really bad heartburn
gin i like but
in small i have to do it in small doses
did she peep yeah admit it
so she's like why are you guys not why
are you not talking to me arena what was
that one remember they had the
butterscotch
butterscotch wasn't it butterscotch
whiskey
what was that we had a honey one no not
that that's something what i'm talking
about uh
there was some kind of a shot that they
were giving us i think it was
butterscotch
i thought well no one
no that was completely different i don't
remember what it was what the [ __ ] was
it
although i will say one of the best
shots that we used to have at eyebar was
the oatmeal cookie shartila says in
moscow mules
it's ginger beer and vodka with lime
never had it
ginger beer with vodka okay that's not
okay that's trying to imagine what
that's thinking about at all
i'm not a huge it's weird because i'm
not a big fan of ginger beer i like
ginger ale
uh ginger beer
i had to drink a lot of it when i was in
the uk because my husband was super into
it yeah it's good but it's just as soon
as i drink it i just start sneezing
uncontrollably
i know it's ridiculous
i can't help it i like it um
i'm trying to think of what else is kind
of like that
if you
well you probably have black velvet
having your tea which is uh
guinness stout
and uh
hard cider
it could be apple or pear any kind of
hard cider 50 50 mix that's good i like
that one
zach says i had some friends who talked
about having whipped cream flavored
vodka once and i puked in my mouth a
little bit um whipped cream vodka is
good i don't know if i'd drink it on its
own because it's a little sweet yes it's
good with it but it's good with orange
juice it's good like mixed with other
things
um because it kind of tastes like a
creamsicle but i was we had she before
this drink she was drinking pinnacle
coconut vodka with uh i do like the
coconuts yeah with uh pineapple juice
it's really good if you like malibu very
tropical it's like malibu but a lot
stronger i could drink a whole bottle of
malibu and it wouldn't even phase me i
mean what i love malibu what's what's
that what's the abv on uh malibu because
honestly some beer but not much more
that's what i mean because i kind of
feel like some nights when we go to
eyebar it's like oh we're in like a
tropical jimmy buffett kind of mood so
let's drink some malibu and it's like
you can drink that [ __ ] all night and
you won't even i wouldn't even get a
buzz off that no but if you like that
experience then just get whipped cream
pinnacle vodka pour it over ice and put
[ __ ]
pineapple juice that mexican or
central american pineapple just like
goya
put that in there
stir it oh it's beautiful it's real
beautiful it's just kind of has a pina
colada flavor but it's not a colada it's
you know it's just got ice it's just a
drink
like a screwdriver
getting caught in the rain yeah tila
says bailey's is really good in coffee
yes it is yeah and poured over vanilla
ice cream i love bailey's irish cream i
know i do too i mean it probably has it
has like a zillion calories but
for a while
uh i had a bottle that somebody gave me
like for christmas like years ago and
sometimes in the morning i'm not a drunk
i swear i would put it in my coffee in
the morning she said she's never had
black velvet but i guarantee you
something t your husband gets black
velvet all the time
it's black it's strong it's thick
that's a pretty easy joke though
it's just right there no i was just late
and she she set herself up for it now
you'd like you'd like black velvet tea
it's
a 50 50 mix
guinness extra stout
and any kind of cider but usually
something like angry orchard hard cider
or uh i've had it with the pear cider
yeah i think the first time we had it
was with pear cider which is good but no
that was the first time i had well no i
mean the first time we had it at at that
point at that one place right yeah but
angry orchard will work and it's just a
50 50 mix
and you don't have nothing no special
way to mix it just pour the stout in
first and then just pour the
pour the cider in afterwards and uh you
know it's two drinks for the price of
one put it in tall glass
and it's just it's cool it's very thick
and rich
and the the cider takes
that bitterness out of out of the stout
and it's just like it's like drinking
apple bread or something i don't know
there's no way to [ __ ] describe it it
is kind of like apple liquid apple bread
yeah it is kind of smooth well the only
thing and i think i brought this up
before but some places because like i
said you know liquor license especially
in downtown orlando is very expensive
so you'll have like a lot of these
little
bars or like little music venues and
they have beer and wine but they can't
they don't have a liquor license so they
can't have you know some of they have
like those fake malt liquor things but
so a lot of them will do like craft
beers and stuff so if we go somewhere
like that like the falcon
um then you have to get beer because
they don't have vodka or anything
now beer
i'm not a connoisseur i'm not you know
but those are good but the only thing
about those well okay there's two things
one thing
uh they make me pee like a racehorse
yeah uh two they make me wanna fall
asleep
i guess it's like all the carbs
it doesn't even like get me drunk
necessarily well it does but it takes a
lot yeah i'll usually like get so really
sleepy before i'll get like drunk to the
point where i'm just kind of like i'm
just going to take a nap right here on
the [ __ ] yeah right here on the
[ __ ] bar it just makes me really
really really sleepy
teasing it's about corny of course i'm
corny man [ __ ] issue was coming
i mean he's like he's like the
embodiment of like the dad joke well
yeah yeah yeah sometimes well no no not
all the time not so much dad just you're
kind of like the dirty dad yeah if i see
an eye opening for one i'll [ __ ] i'll
i'll do it uh but no that's and i've
known you for such a long time yeah if i
see one that i'm like a couple steps
ahead like if i see because i'm just so
i'm just sitting there going wait for it
wait for it
yeah
even if i say something yeah
sometimes i say stuff like on purpose
just to like them because i know that
he'll because i'm like oh we're gonna go
to men because he's gonna walk right
into that we're gonna go to man because
tonight well it's only 6 30 right i know
that i'm gonna dance tonight are you
really i'll post that [ __ ] up on the
[ __ ] we should talk about we never
really post on the [ __ ] that we do
monday night yeah we went to momento
mori yeah supposedly the last one well
it's the last one at ibarr barbarella
because eyebar slash barbarella is
moving yeah um so
momento so we did the last one
holy crap everybody came out yeah
everybody i where the [ __ ] were you
people i saw people i hadn't seen in
[ __ ] six years yeah i'm like where
the [ __ ] have you been
so yeah so we did that it was a [ __ ]
blast we had so much fun
that they turned all the lights on at
the end of the night i'm like what the
[ __ ] is going i didn't realize that it
was like [ __ ] 3 30 in the morning i
did not realize and honestly it was um
it was awesome but it was also like
bittersweet because i mean that's such a
great venue
i mean we'll get another one yeah but
i mean that place is kind of like you
know it's it
ibar's been there i know it's called
barbarella now and it used to be called
barbarella but it's confusing
it's been there for what 37 years yeah
so some like man i practically like i
feel like i grew up in that place
so the fact that it yes it's still gonna
be open but they're moving it someplace
else
so i don't know it's like an end of an
era so it was kind of that did i cry a
little bit um but other people did too
it wasn't just me so you know it's not
going anywhere it'll just be in a
different place i know but there are so
many memories tied up in that building
though it was it look
it was starting to get stale even kind
of before covet
covet came it hung on but the rest of
the knights
didn't do well enough
and then um even though florida
is
was probably one of the states least
affected by things it still had a
societal effect quite a bit
because
some people just said [ __ ] it and they
just stayed home they got real depressed
and i'm not talking about mostly
mainstream people goths are already
we're annualed to
[Laughter]
[ __ ] it's always been the end of the
world i was like i've been depressed
since i was like
right it's always busy i was defeated
that's actually that's
that's actually a stereotype i don't
know actually that's what i play against
i play
but it is true to an extent though
because i do you know i have the same
kind of i have a depressive
uh introverted type of personality type
right but i'm aware that i'm like that
so
yeah you know what happened in downtown
is that uh the mainstream clubs that
were brought in the big money [ __ ]
folded
so they so the bartenders got desperate
and uh they started allowing [ __ ] uh
like a bunch of [ __ ] rap nights and
stuff
what tio tell you man the [ __ ] hood
started pouring in there what what they
do they started shooting each other up
i mean there were shootings [ __ ]
happening which drove [ __ ] the rest
of the [ __ ] out it yeah stabilize
eventually but yeah it'll take a while i
mean so much stuff closed in downtown
like clothes or you know people just
weren't bothering to go downtown
and you have to admit too that i bar
slash barbarella
um they had different nights but their
main
thing and always their main thing has
been
new wave alternatives stuff like like
from the 80s like retro stuff they did
90s stuff too they did
recent indeed you know they had they
were all over the place but their core
audience
was always
kind of retro
um and that's you know so their
clientele was getting a little bit older
uh so
a lot of their clientele were like well
when [ __ ] was going on downtown and it's
like oh the crime's getting worse and
they didn't really want to go down there
it's too much trouble
so
even before covid and that didn't help
yeah um
you know people were not going out as
much right and honestly it wasn't even
we didn't even start doing that we
started going out less because it was
farther for us to drive yeah and
particularly when we moved here
now we've moved here it takes us 45
minutes to drive there it used to be
about 20 25 minutes we were done we were
18 minutes from downtown uh where we
were in sanford now it's more like 20 of
like or maybe 20 maybe closer to 30
miles so it actually takes like 45
minutes for us to get downtown orlando
now the thing is it's an easy 45 minutes
it is because it's the route is so
comfortable for us because we we grew up
there basically the past 15 10 years so
it's just like
when you're driving 45 minutes of
well-worn territory that you all you
know real well it's not the same as
[ __ ]
a new place
you know what i'm talking about yeah
because everything is just so familiar
the whole way it seems to go a lot
faster so i mean even mannequins is a
little bit of a haul but it's
that's about 20 minutes from us but what
happened is is that the money from
downtown started to suburbanize
which pissed some people off because
where we are here in sanford now
okay but we're in eustis now right we
were in san francisco no
where where mannequins were mannequins
in sanford now
[ __ ] the ass like chantal chantal
[ __ ] pissed off because the white
people are [ __ ]
legitimate
gentrifying sam it's a hockey invasion
yeah it's a hardware issue going on you
know sure but [ __ ] and they were like
well women hold on i would say [ __ ]
and
oh
we were in we were in chantals and
[ __ ] a bunch of mixed couples and
[ __ ]
and my boy my boy [ __ ] was there
[ __ ] with his white
wife yeah well yeah
well yeah and he's like women hold on
hold on why people bring money
and we're like his girlfriend is white
so yeah
yeah and then like [ __ ] mannequins
that's my friend big tom he's black
and and that's his club
and yeah he's
one of the few black dudes that
understands morrissey
and he he's a goth black dude and he's
well i said we met him yeah his wife
miriam or gina as we call
she's actually she is she uh she's
puerto rican she's puerto rican puerto
ricans are americans you know just she's
puerto rican no i'm just saying yeah
she's puerto rican puerto rican yeah um
and they we met them at ibarr god how
many years ago oh man long time holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah they had been going
there forever we see them like every 15
years and they were
i mean they're like the nicest people
seriously and they are
they would go and they were so into like
the 80s [ __ ] man they're like our age
yeah
um and they had you know they had grown
kids and then they brought their kids
out
and there's a whole it's a whole weird
thing i guess
maybe and maybe it happens in other
cities too but you know all the people
that grew up in orlando going to visage
and the edge and all that kind of stuff
like now that we're all like old farts
and we have kids well i don't but you
know we know a lot of people that have
kids that are like in their 20s
and as soon as their kids were 18
like the parents would take them because
they were like please take us to eyebar
take us to you know the edge or whatever
and like see you would take them and
it's just like that's so weird to think
about well like i said we were at
momento monday night and demetri and jen
brought their daughter who had just
turned 18 and she was so excited she
wanted to go to her first moment and by
the way even though it was the last one
that hookup did happen
did it he's like oh i've been trying to
call her i'm trying to turn the car okay
i
i really hope this does not go badly i
don't we talked about this a little bit
on wednesday i said though you just
she's i don't want to ruin it man she's
kind of young you know what i mean if i
can i told them
that is a you realize that that is a
gothic princess okay she is a [ __ ]
a political figure inside the scene he's
like yeah i know i got to take this i
can't [ __ ] around with that because her
dad you know what i mean
and like yeah everybody knows
he runs the [ __ ] so he's got to be on
his good behavior you know and he's like
well maybe you know she's cool though
i'll just get to know her you know you
know and i said i said dude you're 21
years old she's 18. that's a good age
difference because she she'll respect
your opinion on things and
you have a little bit of a head start
and let's be fair girls at that age are
uh more well yeah they're about to they
tend to be more mature than she is yeah
so the difference isn't as strong as he
thinks it is and i told him i said look
this is what you do just get to know her
okay
and i said in a couple of years maybe a
year or so you might feel a little bit
you you know
she's gonna you know it might feel a
little bit differently because that goes
by real quickly man by the time you and
i said you know to develop a
relationship man you want to be a
friend's first and he's like yeah yeah
which i that's me putting the hook in
his mouth
because i know that's not how i really
go at 20 21 but
yeah i mean well you can tell but
honestly though he's worried that he
will the thing about nick the i think
the reason that i like him even though
he's young enough to be our kid nick is
the local version of sid vicious if he
wasn't on drugs
and
wasn't and wasn't wasn't a [ __ ] a [ __ ]
he's real smart he looks like cowboy so
not likes it [ __ ] skinny cute kind of
he looks like sid vicious a little bit
but
yeah
guy he's got a good head on it show that
he works got a job he's got a car
at 21. i mean he's pretty much got his
[ __ ] together i mean he has [ __ ]
together like way more than i did at 21.
yeah you know right that's why i'll give
him that right like i said he has he has
like a steady nine-to-five job he works
in a print shop um you know he seems to
know like
he's got a good head on his shoulders so
i was kind of worried about and i did
i did it with t good women isn't this
the guy with the d with the older lady
yes it is
it is but the thing is is that this is
the god scene
no one's that worried about it they're
not worried about it
okay
it's kind of like
she was handling her business as a goth
queen okay she's initiating the young
man into the world all right
it was a wild night
and yes i i think i think that uh the
boy that we're talking about in
particular probably might need to sow
some oats for a little bit longer
but like i said in a year or two he'll
again he's gonna feel a little bit
different you know what i mean because
he'll be older and she'll be a little
bit older
and i'm gonna show you all a picture who
it is i'm talking about
but yeah but i mean what i was saying so
i talked to dmitry about it because like
i said we were all we were all kind of
emotional because it was the last one
like i said we're gonna do memento
we i mean this night went on for eight
years that's gotta be some kind of
record right yeah i mean yeah well for i
mean for goth nights in this area yeah
uh so eight years
and you know so everyone's kind of sad
about it but dimitri has been messaging
me like all day today and he's like i'm
going to uh soundbar and go to these
other places and i'm going to go and
take pictures and he's like because i've
had a bunch of other offers to do the
night elsewhere
so we're going to see how that uh works
out that's really the only picture he's
got up right now that's in front of
their house yeah because that's we
picked right there all right but um but
yeah so i told them i was like i know
he's like this is a really weird
situation because
i said we've known
demetri and jen's daughter
um since she was 12 12. yeah uh she flew
by she came over to our house and i gave
her a bunch of boots that i wasn't
wearing which is the same shoe size as
me and she was kind of like into gotham
stuff because her parents are as well
and so i was kind of like man i'm not
wearing these have them and she was like
all super cool about it and then she
kind of went through a phase where she
was like [ __ ] that i don't want to do
that anymore because you know she was
rebelling against the parents but now
that she's 18
um she's gone way back into the god
stuff and she really wanted to go to the
club so
monday night was the first night that
she came out
and so
tom who is always
trying to hook people up with one
another he's like the matchmaker of the
goth scene yeah yeah you kind of are
kind of yeah you kind of
he's always kind of if you hear some
people are single or somebody broke up
he's always like he's calculated who can
i hook that person up with
yeah he's like he's like that
so he's like uh so nick came
and he was like oh my god we're gonna
we're gonna make this happen so i was
just kind of like oh my god please don't
[ __ ] this up because like dimitri and
jen are like some of our closest friends
right and i was just kind of like man i
don't want to hook their daughter up
with somebody
i mean you know nick is awesome but it's
if that goes bad i'm just kind of like i
don't want this blowing up in her face
this is why i don't match make because i
don't like [ __ ] blowing up in my face
i'm just like you find your own
boyfriend or girlfriend or whatever the
hell i'm just i'm not getting involved
i don't get involved unless somebody
asks me directly and even then i try to
avoid it
because it's like i i don't know like my
whole life i kind of feel like sometimes
people ask your opinion about something
or ask your advice about something so
that you they can blame you if something
goes wrong you know what i'm saying so
i'm always i'm trying to stay out of
that situation as much as possible so i
did say that to dimitri i said please
if this does not go well
please don't blame me i was just like
but i think they're cute and i think
they they seem to like each other
so
we'll see how that goes we'll see how
that goes trying to find a recent
picture
cat dj maniac says tom tried to set me
up with someone too and i'm all the way
in new york city
i'm telling you man he's kind of like
okay you know you know those [ __ ] uh
like hallmark or the lifetime uh you
know romance movies that come out around
christmas
where
the the meddling mom is always trying to
like set you up with somebody because
you can't be single tom is that person
thomas that person he is always trying
to like [ __ ] engineer
some [ __ ]
you come to tom and be like man my
boyfriend just left me or whatever he'll
be like okay we're going to find you a
new boyfriend like right the only
picture i have
that is close to how she looks now
because she only has a little bit
here's dimitri and there's his little
daughter
that's her that's who we're talking
about but she's got that as hell right
now
she's got like a little fake little
little dimple piercings and [ __ ] her
little septum is done and she's yeah she
has a lot of facial she's there for
facial piercings in that picture yeah
she doesn't have any any any um
now jen has an older daughter yeah
from a previous marriage who is
21 i would say she's yeah she's a few
years older but kat is their daughter
and
i was just i thought it was so funny
because i was just kind of like
man this is it's such a weird it's so
weird
the scene is like so multi-generational
because i kind of feel like when i was
younger
man someone down the wrong way yeah
they're not really the kind i mean you
know the ones that we hang out with
they're not the kind where they're like
giving their kids drugs at 12. it's not
like it was back in the [ __ ] punk
rock scene
or anything they they treat yeah i don't
know anybody that doesn't know they're
all tend to be pretty strict they treat
them as kids until they eat until
they're 18 then they can go to the club
and then just cut them loose
pretty much that's what i've been which
i kind of feel like that's probably what
you should do yeah
i mean
the thing i i guess the reason it's i
mean it's not weird it's awesome
actually but the reason i think it's
weird is that because
when i turned 18 i don't know it would
have been weird
i mean my mom wasn't real my parents
weren't really into a scene when i was
18.
i kind of feel like it would be weird to
hang out with your parents at that age
but in the goth scene it's not weird and
i guess it's like not i don't know
so it's almost like we have like three
generations going on and nobody thinks
it's weird at all no because angel
brings her daughter
you know and a lot of it is who's grown
and obviously and you know a lot of
people bring their grown kids and it's
like a big event like yeah hey my kid's
18 or my kids 21 it's like they finally
they've been like bugging me to like
come here for like all for all these
years and finally i can bring them so
now we can hang out and all drink
together yeah and i'm like that's weird
but it's also kind of awesome and that's
one of the that's one of the things that
i like the most about this scene i have
to say but yeah so i'm just kind of
hoping
man i'm hoping this works out cause i
don't want that i don't want anybody to
get mad at us because we like yeah
we fixed some people i'm not worried
about it
part of this not to worry about it
it's going to be all right i know but
you know yeah
all right
tom could host a new version of that old
show love connection
i remember that show that was that was
chuck woolery was it not
now that wasn't the one
no that's what's the one i'm thinking of
where they ask you all these really
embarrassing questions
uh
that wasn't love connection
what happened on love connection i
remember watching that show but i don't
remember what happened on it i think i'm
confusing it with
a newlywed game remember peter says oh
lord tom don't show faces i know what
you're talking about babe i'll show
faces if i want to
hopefully nobody's like watching me i'm
like hey why are you showing my face on
there i didn't tell you yeah
and everybody everybody's over 18 i can
show bases
uh cheryl says you can go to the club at
18 there yeah you can't drink you can't
drink though uh but you can go
some clubs uh some clubs are 21 and up
it depends on the individual club eye
bar barbarella uh yes you can go there
at 18 but you can't drink until you're
21. right unless you're well connected
don't say that you're going to get them
in trouble
it's just
right i mean you know because nothing is
in the open air honestly honestly the
liquor licenses in downtown orlando are
so [ __ ] expensive last i heard they
were a quarter of a million they might
be more than that now
um
so people are very very protective of
their liquor licenses
and
uh so they're pretty strict about
underage people they will let 18
and up in
but
you're not allowed to drink and if you
get caught drinking then it's gonna be a
big thing you know what i mean
uh adriana says how has the club scene
changed from the 80s 90s early 2000s
until now
um
let's see
i didn't go to a lot of clubs in the 80s
and 90s mostly because uh for most of
the 80s i was kind of young and then in
the 90s i was old enough but i didn't
have a car or i only had a car like
intermittently whenever i could talk
somebody into driving me someplace
because i grew up in daytona
and we didn't really have any clubs
there
we except for country bars
there were a couple tiny little hole in
the wall kind of punk or alternative
places
but it wasn't really wasn't like a
nightclub situation
the night the big nightclub in daytona
other than the country bar which was
called what was called the rockin
ranch ugh i never went there but you
know what i mean that was the one
everybody went to
but there was one and i think it might
still be there i don't know i've been in
a long time but it's down on the beach
side called seven and one south
and that was like
uh your quintessential
basic [ __ ]
meat market type situation so
i went there one time but i went there
because they had
i think one time in the whole time i
[ __ ] lived in daytona they had like a
new wave slash post punk night
i don't know why i don't know why they
did that
but
so they did do that one time so i went
there then
um and that was fun it's a cool venue
but
normally that was just kind of like that
was where all the spring breaker type
people went and [ __ ] so goth people
would never [ __ ] go there they
usually like drove to orlando or tampa
so after a while in the late 90s early
2000s
i started driving to tampa to go to the
castle
and sometimes if i didn't feel like
driving to tampa to go to the castle i
would drive to orlando
for shows or you know sometimes you'd go
to eye bar you'd go if you're going to
show you go to visage or the edge or
something like that
which were the main places
i don't know
i don't know it hasn't changed that much
to be honest with you i do kind of feel
like when i first started going to the
castle in
whenever the hell it was 1999 2000 i
can't even remember now
um
there was kind of a thing where
i don't know we were talking about this
the other day the goth scene
it almost kind of seemed like it went in
two directions because you had like the
goth scene that went more like in the
goth industrial direction and that kind
of went more into
a [ __ ]
just a dance music techno kind of
direction
and i kind of feel like a lot of that
was going on in the late 90s early 2000s
and i was not about it
so when i first started going to the
castle like the building itself is super
cool and it was like a cool place to
hang out
but a lot of the music they played i was
just kind of like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] it just sounds like the same song
for four hours i'm just like i'm not
into it
um but it was still like a cool place to
go
so honestly if i had my choice and when
i
ended up moving to orlando
i started going to eye bar which is you
know like i said now barbarella
because that was like 80s
new wave 80s alternative and that was
pretty much what they focused on and
it's like sometimes they'd you know
throw a curveball like the cramps or
something and i was just kind of like
all right this is more along the lines
because like i said i don't mind some of
the goth industrial stuff but after a
while it gets kind of like oh this all
sounds the same
and
late 90s early 2000s you also had the
additional problem
of all the manson kids
who were
you know the the kids that hung out at
the mall and would like go to hot topic
with the gigantic pants
and they got old enough to go to clubs
and so their
uh musical taste
which was kind of terrible was kind of
starting to take over and for for some
time i was just kind of like i don't
even know if this is like even the scene
for me they kind of look like me but
they're not really like
representing what i'm all about
so
i kind of went into for a while i went
into um the more the more kind of like
uh the death rock revival which happened
like in the early to mid 2000s so i went
to a few things in like new york and
stuff like that because they had like
all these death rock bands that played
and i was more into that like more of a
throwback to like
punk rock
like old [ __ ]
and i liked that more than the kind of
but honestly it hasn't changed a great
deal
um the club nights we go to now are more
of like a mixture because now a lot of
the [ __ ] that i didn't like
no hey what are you doing stop tearing
up she's just gonna
no
a lot of the stuff that i that i didn't
love from like the late 90s early 2000s
is now
old
so you know there's a generation that
have grown up with that music so now
that's retro
so most of the nights we go to look at
manic like if you go to mannequins for
example like on a friday night
uh like we might later
you're gonna hear everything we're going
yeah you're gonna hear everything from
late 70s punk
to
2000s
electro
um it's just whatever
uh that's kind of like alternative or
there's sort of like goth adjacent or
industrial adjacent
um and i guess that's kind of like the
best way to do it so there's like a lot
of variety like i said you know for one
second like he'll play nick cave and
then he'll play [ __ ] lady tron you
know what i mean uh so it's kind of all
over the place and honestly i kind of
like that better
i like it better when it's just
you never know what you're gonna hear
next like [ __ ] last time we went we got
there early he played the fall
and then he played
um
he was playing like some old [ __ ] he
played like the fall he played like
blondie he played like some old stuff
and then he played what the [ __ ] was
that he plays like a kind of a lot of
90s stuff but he plays like a lot of new
[ __ ] too
but
that's paul vayne and he used to uh he's
our age or [ __ ] older he's older than us
yeah he used to dj at visage but not
much though he's kind of like legendary
he's not much older in orlando because
he used to do he's only a couple years
older than me i think oh
okay so it's almost seven now
when do we have to start getting ready
to go
um because i have to eat too
yeah i mean i'm all right i kind of
already know what i'm going to wear it's
not going to be too
all right i can just like [ __ ]
so the question was is how much time do
we have
i don't know
okay half an hour and half an hour okay
we're all right all right yeah cheryl
said we called them mansonites yeah we
did too so yeah
um it's all gone
yeah nobody does that all got
incorporated i mean nowadays yeah
nowadays people are all old now they're
all hanging out well that's what's funny
is that nowadays you go to mannequins
yeah and they'll play marilyn manson
and back in the old days like all the
old gods would be like oh [ __ ] me they'd
be like roll their eyes but now
everybody's just like
whatever
whatever
we're tired of fighting it or like i
said some of like the people are young
enough to remember tina said i just saw
a video dave billy's man who saw the
world loved it added to my playlist yeah
man who sold the world was a weird song
because he's going up the stairs and
down the stairs he saw himself he's
talking to himself he's in another
universe
i'm not sure exactly who it is he's
talking about
um
for a minute i thought he might have
been talking about adolf hitler
the man who saw the world there were
millions of people uh of all the
millions here i thought you died a long
time ago
yeah but that's pretty vague i mean yeah
it's kind of vague i thought
because he mentioned joseph goebbels on
that same on a couple of other albums i
didn't know if he was talking about
hitler or because a lot of you don't
know it but
bowie was kind of fascinated for a while
about the third reich about how that
could have happened what were those
dudes like i think a lot of people were
fascinated by that because like what the
[ __ ] were they thinking like what were
they thinking what were they like uh
because the information was harder to
find back then um in the 70s
uh but no that's that's a good song
though did you see uh
did you did you get a chance to listen
to [ __ ] the sisters of mercy album and
this joy division and bananarama and all
that that i recommended because you said
you put added that to your playlist
see i love all that kind of [ __ ] well
not poke
i mean still
bananarama's one that people go tom
listens to bananarama i like that
because that was the question who do you
listen to you wouldn't people didn't
think that you listened to
bananarama i liked your banana ramen
that was like one of the original girl
bands
well another thing too you like musicals
yeah i like musicals also not all of
them i don't like all of them either but
good ones like you really like grease i
love grease i do too love it um
[Music]
so maybe my fair lady i liked it yeah so
people might be surprised by that yeah
um you know i like a lot of musicals too
although i tend to like weird ones like
head big and the angry inch and rocky
little picture i really liked um
um
phantom of the paradise uh rebecca
yeah repo was good i keep wanting to
like i keep putting that in the patreon
poll like to review it and it never wins
they probably don't know what you're
talking about but
i mean we should do it anyway probably
because i think it's on to be she saw
repo and i'm not sure she she said she
liked it but not that much
um it's it's
what's funny is that you look at repo
and you would think that that was almost
futuristic or contemporary but it's old
now
um
it's a good it it's a good goth
industrial opera
yeah which i'm surprised there's not
more of those yeah
i mean you know that seems to be the
only one and to be honest
uh that song from it
uh what's it called xi
anatomy we played they played it they
played it last monday yeah he plays at
almost every moment yeah
well i don't know if i want to say that
but he plays it pretty often so that's
like uh i also
like xanadu
uh i really liked uh sergeant pepper's
lonely heart club i love that movie it's
terrible but i love it cheesy tacky got
it so yeah the [ __ ] beegees
i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] i saw it so
many [ __ ] times so many [ __ ] times
t says you saw listen to bananarama
listen to cruel summer yeah
i had about did you like crossover that
was a good one
another one is another good one that
they did was uh robert de niro's waiting
i liked that one too
robert de niro's waiting talking italian
talking italian
it ran's good was good
our shit's going like red again but
hopefully well no it did it it has been
like kind of flipping back and forth
so hopefully it disconnected but then it
reconnected right they did a bunch of
cool um it was just a pop band
but what was cool about them is that
they were not made
by a record industry they they started
off they were just made by themselves
they were just
three kind of
kind of like punk rock girls
it's it was red i know
i don't know if it's [ __ ] playing or
not
i'm going to let it go green
yeah don't talk when it's right there
it's just green yeah nope
nope
nope i told him i was like man when it
goes red don't talk yeah because i don't
it's probably not gonna
it usually even cuts off before you
realize it
because i've had that happen before
don't
oh [ __ ] come on
god damn this that [ __ ] thing
come on
come on i'm trying to like magic power
it into [ __ ] you know
uh
let's see where where are we oh
somebody's talking about head the
monkeys movie yeah i've seen that good
return a living dead should be turned
into broadway play honestly i kind of
feel like there was a kind of a trend
for a while for turning like horror
movies into musicals which you know i'm
all about that
um lame we can't listen to music on
fridays i mean we could i'd have to like
you know i'd get complaints about it
so there's that
uh
yeah where was i okay phantom of the
parish yeah we're back okay because the
the router seems to defined yeah we're
back okay must have just had some kind
of
you don't know what it was i don't know
it was router seemed to be fine i didn't
want to press the reset button because
then there's like a whole minute because
then i have to like really [ __ ] boot
the whole thing and it's just kind of
like jesus christ and i'm done
having it
what was bananaram is that it was an
all-girl bent
it sounded very poppy but
it was but it was
it was made by them
the [ __ ] it's red again yeah
come on
making me mad
yeah
tom leaves and it starts working
one of the one of my favorite one of my
favorite things i never could get what i
wanted to say out [ __ ] all right good
one of my fa even the algorithm is just
like stop talking tom yeah stop talking
about it
stop talking about banana ramen yeah um
it's all that it's illuminati doesn't
like bananas
they know my nut in my voice
he preaches the truth we have to shut
his ass down
okay uh
holy lag batman yeah we're back and
we're back
yeah
i don't know what the problem is it's
fine it's fine banana ramen i didn't
have poppy as [ __ ]
it was but they were self-made there was
no record company behind them one of the
best little dance moves that they did
they were just coming up with that [ __ ]
one of the best things about the 80s in
my opinion and i think why a lot of
people uh even really young people still
uh resonate with that nowadays like i
said you have a whole [ __ ] there's a
whole subculture on tick-tock man that's
like [ __ ]
not even it's millennials kids man that
are all like into 80s life
um
one of my favorite things about the 80s
is that
we had this like
what on the surface seemed to be like
throwaway pop music
but if you listen to like the lyrics and
stuff they were always about something
like really [ __ ] up you know what i
mean like for example
99 red balloons sounds like a cool pop
song it's about nuclear war
enola gay by omd that's about like the
[ __ ] tropic the dropping the atomic
bomb uh is what that's about so i i
really really like that juxtaposition
um
and it's almost kind of like early
trolling where it's like we're gonna
make this happy ass pop song that all
these people are gonna dance to because
they're not listening to the words but
the words are about they were almost all
about like [ __ ] nuclear war and all
[ __ ] like that and i i just i really
really liked that i don't know why but
even now that's a grammar or ram a
banana
rebecca says
oh well i want to address this um oh
wait it goes red
it was me talking that time so
it must be my fault
nobody likes us to talk about bananarama
yeah
okay bananarama run the world secretly
maybe it's porn yeah maybe that's what
it is maybe they think it's [ __ ] poor
maybe bananarama secretly runs the world
and we're not allowed to talk about it
they're like lizard people that's a new
thing that i'm going to start those are
people
know that bananarama are lizard people
and that they run the world
rebecca says i lost interest in duran
duran after arcadia and the power
station notorious didn't really uh feel
joy for me but i loved you but loved the
wedding album you know what i have
great i had the same experience at the
time though i i will say that
i mean and still nowadays my my favorite
duran durant albums are probably the the
first two
uh you know duran duran and rio uh seven
of the ragged tigers pretty good too but
yeah after they split up and they
started doing i love the arcadia album
power station one i bought it but i was
just kind of like man just it just was
very standard to like hard rock and i
was just kind of like yeah what okay
whatever but you know i liked arcadia
because it was a lot more prog rock a
lot more creative and i was kind of more
into that
uh notorious i bought it loved it now
interestingly i didn't love it at the
time i did like love a couple songs on
it
but the first time i heard it i was kind
of like
i don't know it's like i don't know if
i'm feeling it and to be honest i bought
um
no i did buy one after that i bought uh
what was the one that came out after
that was it uh
wasn't it big thing
i bought i bought that yeah
and i liked one song off that big thing
wasn't that good and then i was just
kind of like okay well that's enough of
that so i just i didn't buy any more of
their stuff
but then like after a long time went on
and i went back and listened to
notorious i liked it better in hindsight
i didn't like it at the time because i
bought it on vinyl when it came out in
87
and i was just kind of and how old was i
15 15.
and i was just kind of like i liked it
but not as much
but i like it more in hindsight that's
why i'm saying like if you liked
something a long time ago
listen to it now and see like how it
hits you because it might hit you
differently notorious is a much better
album in hindsight for me than it was at
the time i liked it at the time but not
as much as their earlier stuff
notorious in the context of tom
that was me
senior year of high school in sao paulo
brazil
with a [ __ ] bunch of money
[ __ ] having long
marathon [ __ ] sex with brazilian
girls and nightclubs
because in brazil
a [ __ ] 17 year old guy could get into
a nightclub they didn't have drinking
ages and [ __ ] it was [ __ ] wild well
most places they loved it i think even
nowadays in europe they're just kind of
like hey yeah
you look old enough yeah you know well
there was there as long as you weren't
like uh obviously a child yeah they were
just kind of like whatever it wasn't
really a drinking agent
that was that's an american
concept and
that okay now for for our european
listeners
there was a reason for the american
drinking age law because america was a
big country
and we had kids driving huge cars made
in the 1950s at the age of like 13 14.
they're driving these huge solid [ __ ]
steel cars and they were wrecking them
not a great idea they were getting drunk
they were wrecking them they were dying
uh so it's nice and killing other people
killing other people so yeah so it
wasn't quite the same situation it
wasn't puritanic european like oh that
might it might interpret that as
puritanism no it's more about safety
because okay i learned to drive at 13.
uh did i got a driver's permit by 15 or
16 and was driving on the road
if you were to give me that car
and booze together
it'd have been dangerous
i was doing that but
and in granthars who's a cop right now
he was doing the same thing but we we
kept it very much in check
uh we were walking on [ __ ] eggshells
you didn't want to lose
that
driver's permit okay you
duis were serious even back when we were
kids a dui's driving under influence
that was serious even when we were kids
you would lose your driver's license if
you didn't drive in america you were
never going to get a girlfriend never
yeah you're a loser you're a loser
i mean depending where you grew up but
if you grew up in california or florida
or anywhere you actually kind of need a
car to get anywhere
i made it everywhere i mean if you live
in like a big city like new york you
know people don't drive there and it's
not a big deal because you can get
around don't know how to drive never
driven a car by the time you don't need
to you don't need it it's too much
trouble up there um but most of the
united states is not like that down here
uh i lived without a car for a long time
i would not recommend it
i would rather live without a car but
you have to have a car in florida
europeans cannot in california europeans
cannot grab the scope of
of space
the distances involved
you could drive an hour in the united
states and not see anything
in certain places
there are certain places you could drive
four hours and not see anything
well in texas you can drive like [ __ ]
11 hours
[Laughter]
big vast open spaces of nothing right
and just um
there are europeans you could ask like
[ __ ] my friend rob halford from judas
priest he saw now he's my friend now i
don't know how that happened but
leather dad was like wait
like we're friends another daddy's
sticking together but now he goes to
[ __ ] arizona and sees it was arizona
new mexico was arizona he sees the the
american desert the southwest and goes
this is it and he's from england but
he's like this is it this is what i've
been
this is what i've been looking for and
he he lives there to this day he's wrote
written whole songs about being on
motorcycles riding through the [ __ ]
desert
and until you've been through the mojave
desert or anything which i've i grew up
going through the mojave desert my dad
driving and [ __ ]
it's like something out of the movies
out of like hills have eyes you can
drive for hours through the desert on a
paved road
and maybe pass a car or two
that's why they make so many horror
movies yeah because you break down out
there you're
[ __ ]
but it's a [ __ ] experience
to be out there on a motorcycle it's
like driving across the surface of mars
there is a romanticism to it there's a
beauty to the desert
and uh i got middle eastern uh listeners
like saad and saudi arabia and
everything you know when i went to egypt
in the sinai peninsula in the sinai
desert it's that same feeling of peace
it's a the desert is a spiritual very
beautiful spiritual place
it's rough hot
but it's very dry
and there's something kind of comforting
about it
but it's deadly
a couple days without [ __ ] water and
you're a dead man it's like a hundred
people if you've ever seen i shouldn't
be alive
a lot of those are people that were like
hey i was just driving
uh you know i was doing a road trip out
to see my family in california from
wherever the hell they were we were
driving across the desert we thought
everything would be fine yeah you break
down
uh you don't have enough water
a couple days later you're dead and the
vultures are eating your ass it's not
funny but you know that's what happens
one of the weirdest experiences i ever
had was as a young guy leaving the damn
patrol vehicle i had permission i said i
i asked [ __ ] sergeant smith who's a
friend of mine we used to listen to cure
and [ __ ] together he's a god [ __ ]
sergeant my [ __ ] sergeant [ __ ] 100
first airborne was [ __ ] squadly at
the time he was a [ __ ] he was goth
and i said i want to go back to that
bedouin village i'm gonna go look at
those camels he's like all right it was
about two miles away
we had the vehicle had to stay in one
position but i walked two miles back to
the bedroom village that we had passed i
had a [ __ ] m203 grenade launcher and
all my equipment i had grenades and
[ __ ] live ammo and everything and
went back to go see those camels and
those camels [ __ ] freaked out when
they [ __ ] saw me
and the better ones came out they're
like what did what are you doing i said
no i've never seen the camel some of
them spoke english the better ones the
camels are like we never saw a wet dude
either what the hell what the hell i
hung out for about four or five hours
with with with egyptian bedouins
and had a good time [ __ ] drinking
carcade which is like a little tea that
they make
trading cigarettes and playing cards and
um
guy came he wanted me to pull his teeth
and i said man i'm not a dentist i can't
pull your teeth you know this is
asking any random dude are you a dentist
yeah yeah i really need these teeth
pulled out yeah can someone please do
this
i'm looking at this just either a
dentist or a sadist somebody that says i
can't pull teeth you know and he said no
you can do it
he wanted me to get the tools from the
truck to pull his teeth as his i don't
know how to pull the teeth can you
imagine how much pain you'd have to be
in to just be asking random
[ __ ] to pull your teeth out
well i had a power tools
i had a first aid kit i had a first aid
kit my [ __ ] butt pack
and butt pack that sounds sexual but
back in the days it was just a little
pain oh you know all about butt butt
packing people's butts
[Laughter]
i had motrin in there you guys from the
90s know all in the army know all about
wait you all had periods and you had to
take
no they would give us motrin if you ever
even they would give
every [ __ ] us army soldier back in
the 90s carried around all kinds of
motrin
which is funny because i know motrin is
just like a generic painkiller but i
always associate motrin with periods
even though i have to say
i don't have periods anymore but when i
did
motrin did not do [ __ ] no bernie that
stuff they really didn't do [ __ ] for us
either
great believers of motrin pampering
worked kind of
um aspirin worked but you had to take a
bunch of them
yeah otherwise she couldn't walk well i
had a whole bunch of motrins so i gave
that dude probably about 50 tablets of
[ __ ] motrin now don't take these all
at once
even though they don't do much of
anything yeah and [ __ ] uh
so then later on i go back to the
vehicle and then [ __ ] pull the rest
of the shift there at the vehicle
position which is some weird [ __ ] we're
out and doing desert patrol
the a wax a wax planes watching us
and then we drive back to go back to the
main highway to pass the bedouin village
and the whole village wave and thank you
yeah thank you for the brother yeah yeah
i'm like that motrin doesn't work as far
as i know it may work for them i don't
work for them but you know that was all
i had to get him you know and honestly
it might work for other people because i
have heard about it but well everybody's
different yeah i'm just gonna say that i
took motrin a few times for like i said
female problems and it did not do jack
yeah didn't do jack pamper worked better
but like i said
uh i always took like double the dues
yeah so
and even then
it was still
it didn't fix it it was just well at
least i can walk up right now tila's in
there laughing about you and your
periods emotions and [ __ ] i know well
you know
i don't have any shame
oh somebody asked uh adriana says visage
fade to gray is awesome yeah
sophisticated dark and weird steve
strange is quite underrated okay check
this out
check this out
right here
this book right here
i have this book and it's all about
steve strange he wrote it about uh my
ex-husband's
mom my ex-mother-in-law
was friends with steve strange's mom
because steve strange's mom
lived in wales where i used to live
uh so i actually met steve strange's mom
isn't that weird at some point uh steve
strange is he died right i mean he's
dead now i thought he died
yeah
and uh so yeah so i met his mom
just completely randomly
and i was just kind of like this is the
weirdest [ __ ] ever i was just like yeah
i'm a big fan of your son this is like
so weird it was it was very weird and it
was just like this little
this little old lady in this normal
house in wales
and i was like
your son is like famous worldwide is
that that's
like so bizarre but yeah it was like it
was one of the weirdest things ever um
yeah somebody's talking about like cars
honestly if i
that's another thing i'm not super into
i do not like to
okay i'm not gonna say i don't like to
drive
well i don't like to drive but
it's not so much the act of driving
i don't like
it's all so much driving i don't like
i don't like all the other people on the
[ __ ] road that are in the way
um
i don't like and especially in orlando
because
in orlando and i know everybody says
this in orlando everybody that lives
here
very few of whom are actually from here
originally because everybody moves here
from all over the country and from all
over the world because the weather's
nice
so they bring
to
the situation
and it's not always harmonious let's say
that
so every time we have to drive on i4
um
i kind of like tom dilutely not driving
because it's too stressful but even when
he's driving
i just i'm just sitting there in the
passenger seat like this we're just like
i don't even want to look
because
inevitably there will be some jackals
that are like racing each other and
they're like let's see how close we can
get to all these other cars and just oh
my god it's i can't even stand it so
there's that so to be honest um
i didn't learn to drive until i was in
my
mid-20s probably
wow oh my god why are you what are you
talking about yeah what'd you talk about
what are you talking about
yeah
she's talking
but i mean if i could live without
having to have a car my dream
i think it oh it disconnected did it now
who knows back green no it's not okay it
was yellow it's almost time it's almost
time to end the show anyway
7 23 no i'm just saying that
you know
that's you i mean you you don't mind
driving i don't really like driving i
never really did um
to me it just seems like a big hassle
it's an expense that i wish i didn't
have to pay yeah so
yeah i kind of like everything to be
within walking distance i like that
i like that tina's in there [ __ ]
comment about pokey she must have saw me
kissing pokey
pokey does all kinds of cutie [ __ ]
um that that uh those carnitas
downstairs are [ __ ] smelling great
which tells me that that's almost ready
to go and it is coming up on 7 30
which means that it may be time to start
to shut this down
maybe
i mean you can i know i'm having a good
time but yeah um you can if you want to
finish the show yourself you can but i
think i need to get down there and start
working on well no that's okay because
yeah we talked about we're probably
going to go to mannequins tonight yeah
we got to start getting ready even
though yeah so right
at least i got a head start in the
drinking
yeah yeah yeah
yeah and i don't want to drink something
look at what i got left i don't want to
drink much more because i have to drive
there
yeah i mean it's not that far but i have
time to [ __ ] kind of get some of that
well it doesn't really open until like
nine or ten actually nobody even gets
there until 10 or 11.
so
don't worry too much about it i just
want decent parking you know and it's uh
it's a while from here we got i gotta
make some meat that's true okay all
right so all right we've been on for a
little while
uh so yeah we'll we'll go out a little
bit later
and uh we'll see you guys wednesday or
actually no uh monday sunday sunday okay
sunday we're gonna talk about
gator yeah we're gonna do gator yeah
we'll do gatorade okay i don't know i
don't know if y'all have saw white
lightning
uh which we reviewed we reviewed a few
days ago
great movies we saw the sequel ish
they're playing white lightning and the
sequel gator
on um
youtube
or no it's am yeah it's youtube that's
youtube both of them uh free with
commercials
uh they're playing them without
commercials for free on amazon but
they're uh bert reynolds classics
southern movies made by southerners for
southerners uh very accurate say uh very
accurate
um
uh uh
fair portrayals of the south of the
seventies plus i i know because i was
there as a little kid i had totally
forgotten that gator had lauren hutton
in there yeah
yeah
towards the end of it [ __ ] gator
becomes like a romantic figure with
self-sacrifice baby you go on your way
to your great i was into that yeah yeah
yeah it was just i liked that and uh
they were very ahead of its time they
were kind of the kind of the
redneck version of a rudy ray moore film
but the budgets were bigger
uh
burt reynolds directed gator the second
one
uh and i think he did a pretty good job
and i could see why he was the figure he
was now because when i first the first
burt reynolds movies i saw as a kid was
smoking abandon
and i was like who's this dude i liked
it but i didn't know who he was and he'd
been around for a while i didn't realize
he had been around for a long time and
he'd been doing action roles
and
he was a cool actor he was cool dude and
he was from georgia and
just a southern star from back in the
old days they were not hollywood movies
they were
southern movies you know
uh independent films and they were good
they were good it stands the test of
time there we go he was kind of like
gator was his name was gator mccliskey
mccluskey mccluskey mccluskey
gary mccluskey was kind of like the
redneck james bond
yeah coming out of prison to go do
something for the feds you know that was
that kind of [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's living in a damn shack fishing you
know
as one although he didn't live in the
shack he was just they were just i think
that was just the fish that was the
fishing camp yeah he didn't live in it
and then he's got to deal with [ __ ]
organized crime and he don't like it
again working for the gangsters
there's just good movies i hate having
to deal with organized crime while i'm
trying to like just hang up my fishing
shack
he was kind of like uh
kind of like the original [ __ ] uh
from walking dead it was uh daryl kind
of like the original daryl from the
walking dead
uh he had more lines
taylor would love him
he had more luck he had more lines than
daryl
tina would love that [ __ ]
yeah daryl's uh the strong and silent
type yeah yeah all right so uh yeah it's
friday night we've been going for two
and a half hours which i guess this is a
long enough time we're having a good
time but
uh yeah we're thinking about going to
mannequins this evening
and we gotta have some [ __ ] tacos or
something before we go so we don't get
into bigger trouble
uh yeah norman reedus yeah normally yeah
yeah
uh
c white lightning is for free on youtube
and then gator the sequel
yeah we're going to talk about gatorade
we're gonna we talked we could talk
about gator [ __ ]
was it sunday sunday sunday yeah yeah
it's our matinee show outside yeah
we already talked about white lightning
we did yeah all right i mean it's going
red so i kind of feel like are you going
to be all right
okay
all right so thanks everybody for
dropping by thanks everybody for super
chats thanks for hanging out with us on
this friday night everybody have a good
start to your weekend we will